Good morning, everyone. Welcome to day two of our March 2021 board meeting. We'll start
by establishing a quorum. So Brooks, can you please call the roll?
Member Sun. Present.
Vice President Strauss. Here.
Member Rucker. Member Rodriguez.
Morning, here. Member Petillo-Brownson.
Here. Good morning. Member Navo.
Here. Member McQuillan.
Here. Member Glover-Woods.
Here. Member Patel.
Here. Present. Darlin Hammond.
Here. Member Burr.
Good morning. We have a quorum established.
Okay, good morning. I'm going to start with just the general announcements. For those
who wish to dial in for public comment, members of the public should view the live stream
of the meeting to know at what time we will ask for public comment for each item on the
agenda. Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number and the participant
access code and then following each of the operator's prompts. Upon dialing in, callers
will be added to a caller queue. The operator will notify callers when it is their turn to
provide public comment and will also ask the public to call in for public comment to please
turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they're following the live feed to avoid
an echoing effect. Public comment will be limited to one minute for each speaker. Board
members, please mute your microphones when you're not speaking and keep your cameras
on at all times except during scheduled breaks to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout
today's virtual meeting. If you do need to take a break, please do turn your camera off
at that time and try to space your break so that we maintain a quorum. For each item on the
agenda, there will be an opportunity for you to raise your hand and use the Zoom participant
window if you'd like to ask a question or make a comment. And we're going to begin with item
three. Item three is the approval of indicator 17 of the state performance plan and annual
performance report for special education. And the CDE recommends that state board approve
the state's systemic improvement plan prepared by the special education division to be
submitted to the federal office of special education programs by the mandated submission date
of April 1st, 2021. This item will be presented by Heather Kalanis and Shiloh Bessemil of the CDE.
So please begin. Hi. Good morning. Good morning. All right. All right. Good morning, everyone.
I'm Heather Kalanis, the director of the special education division. And we're here today to talk
about the state systemic improvement plan or the ESSEP as we like to call it as an acronym.
So we'll head to the next slide. And actually, we'll walk through and really talk about what is
the ESSEP, how did we get here, how is it going currently in terms of implementation, and then
talk about next steps towards the end of the presentation as well. The ESSEP is, as Dr. Linda
Darling-Hammond stated earlier, is it's part of the annual performance report and state
performance plan that the board approved in January. The APR includes 17 indicators that measure
outcomes for students with disabilities. And so the ESSEP actually is the last indicator,
indicator 17. And so we'll talk a little bit about what that means. It's a mix of really compliance
and results indicators as well. The next slide. The ESSEP is really designed to be a comprehensive
multi-year plan that's really focused on improving results and outcomes for students with
disabilities. And so the ESSEP is designed really to be implemented across states in order to have
maximum impact for students with disabilities. And so it's a little more dynamic than some of the
other indicators because it is sort of a real-time multi-year process that states undergo.
Next slide. The ESSEP itself covers seven years. So this ESSEP was developed in the 13-14
years. So we are now in really the final year of the ESSEP. And so we'll talk a little bit about
that today and sort of what that means for state of California. The ESSEP is developed in
three phases. And so we'll talk about those phases and sort of what they encompass.
But for your reference and knowledge, we are currently obviously in the last and final phase of
phase three. And the goal of the ESSEP really is to really look at alignment across state and
federal systems so that the students with disabilities are supported sort of within that system
as well. Next slide. And so the phases that I mentioned before, the phase one really is
looking at data and really identifying evidence-based practices that can be scaled across
the state. And so part of that data analysis includes determining a state-identified
measurable result we like to call the simmer. And then a selection of strategies and then
obviously implementation as well. So that sort of bleeds into phase two. And for us, phase two
really in terms of the implementation looked at really sort of that infrastructure development
support for LEAs and the implementation of the best practices as well. Phase three in which we're
currently at now is data before, is really looking at the results, how far did we progress, and
then looking at the consideration of any revisions to the ESSEP as well. Next slide. In terms of
California's theory of action, the theory of action that was developed in 2013-2014 is really
broad, but it looked at the accountability efforts and resources to ensure that they're, one,
aligned and that they're also evidence-based and included in comprehensive plans such as the
LCAP to really meaningfully address students with disabilities along with their peers to improve
outcomes. So really broad ESSEP, but also given the state of California and how big it is in the
various needs, sort of met the needs of California during that time period. Next slide.
These slides here you've seen before, actually you've seen them in January, but just again to
remind the board here that when we're looking at socioeconomically disadvantaged students with
IEPs in the 1920s school year, 13% of those also have IEPs. Next slide. And again, foster youth
again, 20% of foster youth within the state of California have IEPs. Next slide. And then English
learners with IEPs in 1920 with 17% as well. Next slide. And then in terms of students with
IEPs in one or more of the LCFF student groups, we have 70% of students with IEPs that are in one
or more local control funding groups as well. So I will now kick it over to Shiloh to talk a little
bit about the summary of phase two and then talk about phase three as well.
Good morning board members. It's lovely to see you again. As Director Kalamis was talking about
the work we did in the data evaluation and sort of looking at the state of the state, it was very
clear to us that the LCFF student groups and the proportion of students with disabilities within
those groups really made an argument for us to hook into what was already occurring within the
state. Instead of creating a separate process or a separate support system for students with
disabilities, it was important to look at what was already being done. And at that point, and this
was in 2014 and 2015, we had this system of support that was working and the dashboard that was
starting. And so all of this work sort of came together and we decided at the special education
division to really make our SIP part of this system of support. And so as you can see, we sort of
developed, you know, the statewide accountability system became into transition and we sort of
outlined the changes into the state infrastructure that we needed to make so we could align both the
SIP work and our work really with students with disabilities with what was happening already with
LCFF and LCAP implementation. We addressed plans to support our integrated improvement efforts for
students with disabilities. One of the biggest things that we did is we sort of re-lined our
accounting, our monitoring system so that we were using the same indicators. We worked very closely
with our system of support partners and included being at the table talking consistently about how
we can improve both the outcomes for all students because as you know, students with disabilities are
part of the general education population and they are part of their general education students first.
And so we wanted to really make that clear within our SIP that we were part of the system of support
and part of the functionality of improving all students. So this was really reiterated, a coherent
approach and offering support to LEAs who identified both in our monitoring system as being support
for students with disabilities but also through the dashboard differentiated assistance. As you
remember, the first year that we identified districts as being in differentiated assistance, well
over 60% of those districts were identified because of their outcomes for the students with
disabilities student population. So it was really important for us to make sure that we were working
in step with the system of support. So as you know, phase three was spanned five years with a
report on the progress and our results for the SIP implementation. This report here covers the
fifth year that you're looking at of phase three and implementation and provides sort of a general update
on our implementation process. As you will probably see through our submission that our state
identified measurable result, affectionately known as CIMR, is assessments in both English language
arts and mathematics for students with disabilities. As you know, that kind of causes a little bit of
interesting quandary for us going forward and we'll talk a little bit more about that in a moment.
But what we really looked at, what we wanted to see was if we hooked into identifying districts with
the dashboard indicators and working with the system of support, we believed that that would help
improve outcomes not just for students without disabilities but students with disabilities as well.
And so we would see the increase in those assessment scores overall. As you know, COVID has changed
many things in the world and one of them is our available data for the CIMR. So this is the
based on 1920 and as you know, we received a policy letter, the U.S. Department of Education issued a policy letter
on March 20th and so we do not have any assessment data because California did not give the assessment
and the statewide assessment in 2019-20. But that doesn't mean we haven't made any progress and
Director Calamese is going to talk about some of the work that we've been doing and we also have guests
that are going to talk a little bit more about the work that we've been doing.
During this year to really improve and address some of the concerns that have come up
through LEAs around students with disabilities and their progress.
So Director Calamese is going to talk a little bit more about some of the work that we've done.
But I wanted to sort of highlight the work that we've done within the system of support.
Again, we have talked a lot about the disparities in the work there, our work around
disproportionality, our work within the SELPA leads which we're going to talk a little bit more about
and also the work we've been doing to improve access through our
supporting inclusive practices project. So this is really all the efforts we've been sort of offering
through both the system of support and for our students and our districts who are struggling around
outcomes for students with disabilities. And that was really the biggest part of our work
inside of this, inside the SF. So as you'll see, we'll talk a little bit more about that.
But we wanted to highlight the process that we went through. We started with looking at our data.
And those are the charts that you see affectionately known as the Pacman charts where you see the data
really shows that when you're talking about the LCFF student groups, you're not talking about students with disabilities
separate. They're part of those groups. And so it made sense to us to hook into a much larger system.
What that meant for us over time and over the last five years is that our SF has been
about statewide implementation in many states across the country.
Their SF started very small, a few schools in one district or a couple of districts
and with an attempt to scale up. We did not take that approach here in California.
The approach we took was we're going to start with everyone and we are going to do as much as we can
within the system that we believe will work and that is through the system of support.
And so that is the process that we've been working through these last five years.
And so I'm going to send it back to Director Calamese so she can talk a little bit about the efforts that we've been going through this year
that have really rounded out this asset.
Let me unmute myself. In terms of, I think we can probably go to the next slide.
In terms of actually the partnering with our self assistance improvement leads, as you may or may not know,
our SELPA improvement leads are located in El Dorado County SELPA, West San Gabriel,
and then the Riverside County SELPA really serve as our SELPA improvement leads
across the state and have been foundational in this work as they all three really build capacity
across our, you know, in terms of improvement process for SELPAs across the state.
Also looking at developing and implementing new tools and resources for our SELPA leaders to use.
They also launched a series of coffee talks which were virtually facilitated meetings
to really focus on pressing topics and challenges in the field.
And then also the SELPA project also launched the data improvement center
and that sort of data center, if you will, displays six years of state performance
or SPP indicator data and tools to really assist SELPA and LEA administrators
in developing or identifying patterns and trends and data sort of trajectories
so that, you know, folks are able to sort of get down the field and in front of issues
and really identify them and proactively address them before they bubble up
and become problematic across LEAs at the local level.
So that tool is really useful in sort of looking and projecting down the field
and really offering real-time data to our community in the field.
You can go to the next slide.
In terms of the sort of next subset down are the content leads.
And so our content leads really are focused on implementing and providing
evidence-based practices to really effectuate change for our students with disabilities.
So, you know, just in short, run down the list here.
Our content leads consist of the Imperial County SELPA,
and they serve as a content lead for our duly identified students
who are identified with a disability but also identified as an English learner as well.
Our South County SELPA serves as our lead as really through disproportionality
through our equity disproportionality and design project.
Our Marin County SELPA really is supporting the,
in partnership with the California Autism Professional Training and Information Network,
is the lead for really those best practices for students
that are identified across the spectrum, across the state.
We have our supporting included practices,
which you'll hear from a little bit later in just a little bit.
And then we also have the California scale up in terms of our NTSS system statewide as well.
Okay, next slide.
And then...
Sorry, I think this is the point where we're going to go with our guests.
Yep, so at this point, I will hand it over to our guests,
and they will walk us through some of the implementation
and the effects of the implementation across the state as well.
So we wanted to introduce our folks from the Supporting Inclusive Practices Project,
Kristen Brooks and Kevin Schaefer.
They're going to present some of the work that they've been doing this year
across their project along with a couple of LEAs
and sort of highlight some of the successes that they've had
in sort of implementing some of the work even in our current pandemic environment.
So we're very, very happy to introduce both Kevin Schaefer and Kristen Brooks.
I'm going to stop sharing and allow them to share,
and then they will walk you through that.
And then we will finish up the presentation talking about sort of the next steps
around our ESSEP project and our work.
So thank you.
Good morning, and thank you for this opportunity to share our work with you.
My name is Kristen Brooks,
Executive Director with the Supporting Inclusive Practices Project
out of Riverside County Office of Education.
And alongside me is Kevin Schaefer, whom you'll hear from momentarily.
He's the Director of Equity and Inclusion out of El Dorado
and also co-director of SIP.
You'll also hear from educators, leaders, and project partners
deeply dedicated to the work within SIP throughout the state.
But we'd like to first start by sharing about what it is that we do,
for those of you who don't know much about our project just yet.
So our vision in Supporting Inclusive Practices
is to intentionally design equitable and inclusive systems for all kids.
And our tagline here is sort of innovate, include, and impact.
And our mission and focus is to provide tiered technical assistance
to our LEAs throughout the state,
focused on those indicators that Shiloh and Heather went through just earlier
in terms of three, five, six, and seven.
And those are focused on least restrictive environment or inclusion,
as well as achievement for kids pre-K through 22.
And this tiered technical assistance is in the form of one, tier one level
is providing professional learning and thought partnering
and sharing resources with anyone throughout California
who's interested in increasing inclusion and achievement
for students with disabilities.
But really we're talking about all students.
Once we start saying we're just talking about students with disabilities,
we're doing the opposite of inclusion, right?
We are by default starting to segregate kids.
So we're really talking about how do we address the needs
of all marginalized populations throughout the state.
So this professional learning and thought partnering
and resource sharing is at no cost to anyone in California.
At a tier two level, we have 50 grantees across California,
and they are really focused on that direct,
we're working on direct support with them.
So boots on the ground work and looking at what is their current state
and their desired state and how do we get there.
It's not a toolkit saying this is how you do inclusion
or this is how you reach these achievement milestones.
It's really about what's unique to their culture and their community
and walking alongside them in this journey
and providing that support along the way.
At a tier three level, that's when the department contacts us
and asks us to provide project support or webinars
or convene and work with a different district
who may not be a named grantee.
Secondly, we support those leadership teams
and their intentional design and sometimes redesign
of their systems and support.
Sometimes we have to take a couple steps back
to take a few more steps forward, and there's nothing wrong with that.
Again, we're meeting folks with where they're at.
And then lastly, it's really about envisioning those outcomes,
building capacity, and ultimately want to implement and scale
and pay it forward and serve as a model for others,
and focused on culture, policy, and practice.
So what do we believe about kids?
What are those policies that enforce what we believe?
And then what are the practices happening in the classroom?
We don't want to just put fancy vision and mission statements on the wall
and say, you know, we hope to get there,
but really how are we impacting kids down at the classroom level?
And so this is just a quick graphic
about where our grantees are throughout California.
You can see very far down south, anyone from Los Angeles Unified,
a large district of Ventura County,
all the way up to Wairika Union and Siskiyou up in the north.
So we are throughout California and really, again,
working alongside in a very organic process with our districts
and supporting them to get where they want to be, to hit their targets.
And just a caveat, if you look at any of our final reports,
you'll see that our districts are increasing in inclusion and achievement
anywhere between 5% and 12% across three years,
so longitudinally as high as some of our outliers in 24%.
So we're making huge gains in inclusion and achievement for our kids.
And we really believe that it's because of this relationship
and this organic walking alongside folks
and serving as coaches along the way.
It's not just kind of a one and done support,
but really taking this across time with them towards improvements.
So I'd like to turn it over to Kevin.
Thank you, Kristen, and good morning, board members.
We utilize a blueprint for inclusion to work with our grantees,
knowing that many of our grantees,
some have bought into improvement science through the CILT grant project,
and others utilize implementation science.
So our approach is one of really looking at and honoring the context
in which each of our grantees are implementing inclusive practices.
So as Kristen mentioned earlier, we start with envisioning.
We work with a cohesive leadership team,
and we address the vision, mission, and values that are specific to that LEA.
And honoring that vision, mission, and value statement,
we want to enforce that to move into our behaviors.
And do our behaviors reflect our vision, mission, and values
around all students achieving to the best of their potential?
Once we've defined what our vision is for inclusion, we build the system.
We ensure that the building of the system is created prior to the implementation
of the supports that have been designed around inclusion
before any of the users, the teachers, the families, the students
experience those innovations so that they're set up to be successful
in the implementation process.
And then we want to scale up across the organization, across the LEA,
across the state, et cetera.
And then once we've reached a level of project reaching their scale
that we had expected or envisioned, then we want to pay it forward.
We want to create model sites.
We want to create model organizations so that others can benefit
from the work that has been done.
Next slide.
And you can find out more about the Supporting Inclusive Practice,
this project, from our website at www.sipinclusion,
as well as our social media.
Our focus is to create a community across the state such that we can move
beyond just the 50 grantees that we work with, but influence inclusion
beyond just the Supporting Inclusive Practice project,
and thought partner with others as much as our capacity allows.
And you'll find on our website all of the no-cost registration for our events,
as well as the archives of the EDGE newsletter
and the distance learning innovations for special education.
Next slide.
And what we've learned in our experience over the past six years,
the project has been in existence, is that there's not a toolkit for inclusion.
It's an organic process that honors the context, the initiatives,
the priorities around each individual LEA.
And it has to be intentional design.
That's why we start with the envisioning within our blueprint.
What is the vision and how do we build it?
And that's where the support for Supporting Inclusive Practices comes into play.
And we have to work with school boards, superintendents, and leadership teams,
especially in that envisioning, building, and implementation process.
How do we communicate?
How do we create a sense of urgency within our systems that this work has to be done
in a very thoughtful way, but also with that sense of urgency
that our students are currently moving through the system?
Shiloh had mentioned earlier that students with disabilities are general education students first.
If we don't break down those silos and self-imposed barriers,
then we are creating a bifurcated system in which students with disabilities
will continue to be marginalized and disproportionately represented
in our special education system.
And then finally, we have to change our adult mindsets.
We start with culture.
What do we think about students with disabilities?
Do we own the fact that students with disabilities are not achieving
at the same rates as other students?
We have to change adult mindsets, get the system ready,
and re-culture with a focus on relationships with each other,
relationships with our students, relationships with our families,
and our community stakeholders.
So we wanted to make sure that we left enough time so that we could allow
for our grantees to share the amazing work that they have been doing.
And I would like to hand it over to Heather Richardson,
the Eureka City Schools Director of Early Childhood Education.
Heather?
Hi, everyone. Thank you so much for having me here today.
Like Kevin said, I'm Heather Richardson.
I'm the Director of Early Education for Eureka City Schools
all the way up here in Humboldt County, California.
So with the support of regional and state partners,
including Kevin and Kristen and the SIPP team,
Mindy and our Humboldt Del Norte SELPA,
and now with Patty and the CAPTN program,
our district preschool program, which is Winsler Children's Center,
has reinvented the way that we've provided our special education services
through inclusive practices.
Over the past three school years,
we've moved from a completely separate SDC classroom
to a fully inclusive preschool model in all of our classrooms.
I'm incredibly proud of the hard work all of our early educators
have been doing here every day to build strong foundations
for all of our students,
and the work that's being done here is deepening our connections
with each other, with families,
and has proven to have lasting effects on all of our students' outcomes
well beyond their preschool years here with us.
So the support that we've received from our school district,
the SELPA and at the state level through SIPP,
has helped us reinvent our program,
and it's helped us create a system that will,
while it's still very much in progress,
has become a model for what quality and inclusive practices
can look like in early childhood programs
and how they can be scaled up in other programs across the state.
SIPP grant funding has allowed us to enhance our learning environment
in our own program
and also pursue professional development opportunities,
including sending a team of 11 educators from our school district
and our county office to the California Beginning Together
Inclusion Facilitator Training Institute
all the way down in San Diego in 2019.
Through our program's continuous improvement cycles,
we've identified needs in supporting students with autism,
and through our SELPA, we're able to pursue captain's support
in the use of evidence-based practices,
as well as continue networking with programs and districts
across the state as a SIPP grantee.
And to say that I'm excited to see where we're going to be going next
is a total understatement.
So now I'm going to turn it over to Mindy,
and she's going to share a little bit about the work being done
at the Humboldt Del Norte SELPA level.
Great. Thank you, Heather.
Good morning, everyone, and thank you again.
My name is Mindy Fatig, and I'm the executive director
of Humboldt Del Norte SELPA and the current chair
for the State SELPA Administrators Association of California.
Our SELPA has been a Captain Cadre member since 2013.
Locally, we have seen a tremendous increase
in the number of students with autism over the years,
as I'm sure everyone has had statewide,
and it continues to remain a priority to bring evidence-based practices
in educating our students with autism in the least restrictive environment.
It's also been a priority noted with our local SELPA governance board
to continue the support and have funded a portion of a behavior
since 2013 to provide the support to students, families,
and staff in all of our districts.
For the past three years, SELPA has partnered with
Riga City Schools' Heather Richardson and her group,
Humboldt County Office of Education, and supporting inclusive practices,
the SIPP grant with Kevin and Kristen,
working on providing training, coaching, and support
for successful implementation of inclusive environments.
Again, a focus this year and the last three years
has been on the inclusive programs in the Winsler site,
which Heather talked about.
In addition, Humboldt Del Norte SELPA applied
and was selected to be a regional captain lead
for the coastal region of far northern California,
which Patty's going to talk about later.
We recognize the education historically has been in silos.
Special education, general education,
and even sometimes unintentionally grant work has been in silos.
So this was really a thoughtful, mindful opportunity
to bring the resources and expertise
through the California Department of Education state grants
of the SIPP work with Kevin and Kristen,
with the district, and the state captain regional grant
through the SELPA to bring comprehensive,
collaborative, evidence-based practices to build upon
and expand our inclusive preschool programs.
And of course, as Heather said, they benefit all students,
both academically and social-emotionally,
and especially in our far rural area up here in Humboldt County,
where staffing supports and resources can be extremely challenging.
So we all know it's about providing equitable opportunities
in the least restrictive environment
that benefit all of our students.
We are seeing firsthand the benefit of these inclusive programs
with ongoing staff training and support,
and really a true partnership in learning
with families and students and staff.
I can tell you it's an exciting time up here in Humboldt-Delmar SELPA
to bring the work of the county, the district, and the SELPA
with two state grants to collaboratively pool resources,
expertise, and learn from one another
to better the outcomes for all of our students.
And we are proud of the work of our teachers and admin collaboratively
and what they've done in order to create this model program.
And not only, as Heather was talking about,
we've created this really awesome, fantastic inclusive preschool program,
but we're really setting the foundation of support through SIPP and CAPTED
to expand those inclusive practices throughout the grades,
not only just in Eureka City Schools and their district,
but SELPA-wide in all of our districts, which is over 32 school districts.
So very excited with this work, very excited with the collaboration,
and again, much appreciative to the CAPTED and the SIPP grants that we have.
We couldn't do it without them.
And to discuss more about the important work of the state CAPTED grants,
which has been vital in this work,
I'm going to turn it over to Patty at this point.
Thank you.
As Director Fatig mentioned, CAPTED came into existence in 2013
as a partnership between the California Department of Education Diagnostic Centers,
the Department of Developmental Services, and the UC Davis MIND Institute
in order to implement the recommendations of the Legislative Blue Ribbon Commission
and the Superintendent's Autism Advisory Committee
for improving services and outcomes for students with autism.
In order to disseminate vetted resources and information,
we first developed a website that links users to online learning modules,
infographics, and other resources about evidence-based practices in autism.
This website and its contents are universal support that are available to anyone for free.
As Director Fatig shared, our Tier 2 targeted supports involve our Captain Cadre,
who are deployed through each SELPA to assist teachers in specific classrooms
with learning to implement evidence-based practices
using high-quality professional development practices.
Beginning in 2019, we partnered with the Marin County SELPA
as the SELPA content lead for autism and evidence-based practices
and began offering Tier 3 intensive supports.
These supports are designed to build each SELPA's capacity for supporting their districts
in the use and scale-up of evidence-based practices that will result in improved outcomes.
We've recruited 13 SELPAs as partners in this work
and are training their teams in the use of implementation science strategies and practices.
These SELPAs in turn work with their districts, establishing district teams,
and setting up transformation zones where the infrastructure, systems, and supports are put in place
to begin to scale the use of evidence-based practices across the entire district.
So in this case, Humboldt Del Norte SELPA is one of our 13 SELPA partners,
and they're working with Eureka City Schools beginning at the preschool level
as their transformation zone for using evidence-based practices to improve LRE
capacity for students with intensive support needs such as autism,
with the eventual goal being to scale these practices across the entire district.
Next slide.
In summary, our formula for success is simple.
Evidence-based practices multiplied by effective training, coaching, leadership,
and regionalized supports multiplied by creating the systems within the SELPAs
and LEAs will result in better outcomes for students.
Thank you for the opportunity to share our work with you here today,
and I'm going to now hand it back to Kristin Brooks with the Supporting Inclusive Practices.
Thank you so much. Amazing work you guys are doing. Really appreciate you being able to share it today.
I'd like to now turn it over to Drs. Matheny and Betters.
We're traveling down south here in California now to talk about the East Valley SELPA approach to SIPP
working alongside San Bernardino County Superintendent of Schools.
Thank you, Kristin, and I would like to thank the board for this opportunity.
And we're going to share our journey as we begin to be a recipient of a SIPP grant.
And so to begin with, just a little bit about the East Valley SELPA.
We're a multi-district SELPA in San Bernardino County, and as Kristin said, that's in Southern California.
We encompass five unified school districts and a portion of the county office.
Within those five school districts, we have almost 80,000 students,
and 11,000 of those students are students with disabilities.
Our districts are very different from one another.
Some of our districts are in an urban area, some are more rural, and some are suburban.
But that alone doesn't describe the East Valley SELPA.
We have great differences within our region.
So we are the home of one of the world-renowned medical centers,
Loma Linda University Medical Center.
Just a few miles down the street from that center, we have a growing homeless population.
So we have great differences within our community and our communities.
And what we wanted to do is to take a look at what do we value, what do we do,
and what are our next steps to improving.
And so the East Valley SELPA is known for focusing on parent-school relationships,
particularly alternative dispute resolution.
Not only am I the administrator of the East Valley SELPA,
but I'm also the chair for the State Association's ADR committee,
and I'm the treasurer of the State SELPA Association.
And in those capacities, I've planned, facilitated, and hosted the annual ADR conference.
Last week, we had our first virtual conference and had over 1,100 participants.
It was very well received.
I've also worked very closely with Shiloh and Heather's team at CDE
to assist with the grant distribution for the ADR, ADRE, and ADR COVID grants.
In addition, the East Valley SELPA, next slide,
has focused greatly on improving opportunities and outcomes for students with disabilities.
So we are a regional provider of technical support.
We've made sure that school districts meet the state and federal performance targets
that you heard about from Shiloh and Heather,
and we really have now focused on increasing practices
to include students in all settings who have disabilities.
One of the things we've been doing well is that we have not been identified
as districts that are significantly disproportionate,
but we also know that because of our great diversity,
we needed support, and we needed support via this state grant
to expand inclusion, to expand access and equity.
But where did we begin, particularly this year as a first-year grant recipient
and with a pandemic happening?
Where do we start this work?
And so under Kristen's leadership,
we took a look at what is that first stage of implementing this grant,
and we recognized that it was an organic process
and that it would require us to envision and to change mindsets
and work with our school cultures.
And so what I decided to do was to pull together
the East Valley Self-Assist Leadership Team.
And so on the next slide, you'll see that that encompasses three administrators
from each of our school districts,
as well as our county, San Bernardino County Superintendent of Schools,
as well as our Chief of Equity and Access, lead of the county.
And so we came together, and we began talking about
how do we inspire people to change?
How do we encourage people to take on the shared vision
of including our students in every capacity on educational campuses?
And we knew we were committed to growing and changing,
but we weren't quite sure how we were going to accomplish that.
And so with Kristen's leadership, we dug into a book study.
And so that book study has been going on now since the late fall,
and it's all around, I think it's on our next slide, Kristen,
a book entitled Change the Culture, Change the Game.
And so this professional learning has brought together
these leaders from our school districts,
which include cabinet members, assistant superintendents,
as well as site principals,
and directors of special education and instructional services.
And what I would like to do next is have one of our members,
our Chief of Equity and Access,
talk to you about her experience as being part of this leadership team
and what she's gained from it and what we hope to be our next steps
as we move forward as a grant recipient.
So Dr. Betters.
Thank you, Dr. Bethany. Good morning, board.
So we recognize that we have the greatest amount of diversity
that we have ever seen as a nation,
and that is represented in our current generation of students.
In fact, we know that research tells us
that they are not only the most diverse generation,
but they have the highest of expectations for diversity
as it relates to their daily lives,
which means the adults in their school environment
and their school experience must be inclusive
of those dimensions of difference to ensure a school culture
that is explicit in clarity and coherence
around the results of providing a sense of belonging for all students.
I have heard the words result and goals a few times this morning,
and I think when we talk about goals or results,
it's important that what we are saying
is that we have common language about what progress looks like.
Next slide, please.
So this book study is really helping us as school leaders
create common language about what to focus on in shifting to
or in some cases enhancing an asset-based lens
to teach it in learning as well as school improvement.
I heard that today too.
And transformation of schools that's going to anchor us
to the result of having school cultures that benefit each student
and especially those that have been identified with exceptional needs.
Next slide, please.
Survey. That's not my slide.
Did we skip a slide? That's okay.
And to move from current culture to new culture,
we have to be able to acknowledge difference,
but not to get stuck there.
Peter Drucker says that culture eats strategy for breakfast,
meaning culture shifts occur when people believe at a fundamental level
in the efficacy around inclusive school cultures.
When we talk about educational equity and equitable educators,
we ensure at a baseline that our school environments are welcoming
and wrought with care and joy.
Board, I want you to know our schools will absolutely look different.
You guys know that.
Under the leadership of Dr. Brooks and Dr. Matheny,
this partnership with SIPP and SBCSS through East Valley SOPA
will allow us to ensure that they also feel different.
Thank you for having me.
Thank you so much.
Really appreciate your time and sharing out.
And it's been quite a journey.
I know Kevin and I have just enjoyed working with all of you so much.
And to the board, we really appreciate this opportunity to share.
I'd like to pass it over back to you all.
All right.
Great. Thank you so much, Kevin, Kristen, Mindy, Heather, Patty Times, too,
and Tarina for presenting here today.
I'm just happy to always be in partnership and thank you for spending some time
and, you know, really enjoy sort of walking through your journey with you here today.
So, again, thank you so much.
We can flip to the next slide.
And really towards the back half of our presentation.
So we'll talk a little bit about, first and foremost, I think one of the cornerstones of the SIPP in terms of requirements
is really sort of engaging with our stakeholders and community.
And so, you know, there have been sort of several efforts ongoing throughout the development
and implementation of the SIPP in terms of really, really digging in deep with the community
and dialoguing about the work that's occurring.
And so one of the ways in which we have engaged our community is really through the innovative solutions work group.
And so, you know, with the impact of COVID-19 creating those challenges across challenges for LEAs across the state,
the CDE used this as an opportunity to engage those stakeholders to get the feedback on various topics
related to students with disabilities, outcomes, distance learning.
And so this was initiated by Superintendent Thurman to provide a practical guidance to teachers and administrators
in order to support students and families in the shift to distance learning almost a year ago today.
And so the CDE formed the innovative solutions work group.
The work group had over 130 participants, consisted of parents and teachers, service providers, administrators,
and representatives from other professional organizations.
And throughout the meetings, the participants focused on specific topic areas
and really sort of served as a think tank to really support and offer continuing improvement efforts during the time.
And so some of the topics just included early childhood resources, least restrictive environment,
mild and moderate intellectual, supporting some of the low incidence needs of our students as well,
supporting parents and families, and of course providing and really brainstorming around mental health
and mental health resources for our students as well.
The second is really the CDE began broadcasting webinars every Thursday and covering again various topics
similar to the ones that I mentioned above as well.
And those webinars can still be accessed on the CDE website and still serve as I think a valuable resource across the state even now.
We conducted a survey, and so the survey went out to every special education director and LEAs across the state
really to gather feedback and was used to design some of those webinars and subsequent meetings as well.
And it also helped serve as a guide for how CDE developed the guidance and resources available to the field in the time as well.
And so of the LEAs that did respond to the survey, the results were actually equally distributed amongst
really across the board in terms of geographic location, rural, urban, and LEA size.
So it was a healthy mix and I think a good representation of our state as well.
In terms of ongoing stakeholder engagement, the targeted engagement with stakeholders
was in addition to some of the standard stakeholder engagement opportunities around the ESSEP, the statewide systems support as well.
And so as in prior years, the opportunities include monthly meetings, conference calls with statewide SELPA,
bimonthly meetings with our special education administrators of county offices, regular meetings
with the California Advisory Commission on Special Education or AXE,
and then obviously the state board meetings as well served as stakeholder engagement sessions.
Next slide. In terms of just some long term next steps for us here at CDE,
knowing that we still are faced with the challenges and also really the opportunities to really improve and progress with our system.
Some of our long term next steps really focus and center on remaining engaged in the activities and the efforts
related to the statewide system of support and the special education resources leads,
much of what you heard today, and really maximizing those internal and external partnerships.
The ESSEP, as stated before, will be submitted to those people first.
Next slide. In terms of the immediate, and I think that for us here is really occupying a lot of brain space and manpower
really to address and be responsive to LEA and student need still during this very, very critical stressful time for our community.
And so our focus is to really ensure that IEPs and assessments are conducted and current for each student across California.
And really the goal at CDE is really supporting LEAs in that process and ensuring that IEP teams
and students are working towards relevant, timely and meeting goals and in making sure that system is in place so that high quality supports and services are still being delivered during this time and teams have accurate information.
And as schools open in the fall, are fully open in the fall, students will need additional support.
And so, you know, we'll be engaging again with the field to really learn, you know, topics that are surfacing and really circle back around on some of the guidance and webinars and things like that to provide, again, sort of updated resources and supports.
Again, as we head into the fall months. Next slide.
And in terms of the CDE approach, how will we get there?
You know, our monitoring, we're going to pivot just a little bit and really focus on what we call really the building blocks or some foundational sort of best practices and really building high quality IEPs to support the needs of students.
And we know the IEP is critical. It's a living document and it really provides the roadmap and the trajectory for student success.
So really, really digging in and focusing with supports to our LEAs to really, you know, use relevant data, but also, you know, develop a plan that is actionable and meaningful for the student and can be implemented during this time will really be our focus as well.
We'll continue to build those resources to support the LEAs with those assessments as well and service provision throughout the fall.
As you may recall, we partnered with the California Association of School Psychologists to provide a webinar of assessments in COVID during this time.
And so really ensuring that our community has the resources to conduct assessments, whether that be in person, whether that be hybrid or virtual, still will be an area of concern and focus for us as well.
Positive behavior supports. Obviously, as more students transition back, we're looking at ways in which we can really provide supports in the field around, you know, positive behavior, pro-social behavior and working with our partners across the state to really establish
you know, I think some guidance and resources that will be helpful as students, as more students transition back.
And then continuing to collaborate with our technical assistance partners and really looking at teacher training, professional, paraprofessional training, English learning disabilities, but also, you know, not only continued collaboration, but also, I think, really, really focusing
and accelerating some of those efforts given our timeframe. So, of course, that will keep us plenty busy. And of course, really excited to partner with our self-elites and our content leads to really move the work forward and really assist us through this critical time.
And at this point, that concludes our presentation. And thank you so much. And thank you to our partners who were with us here today and happy to take any questions and go from there.
Also, President Darling-Hammond, this item will require action. We do need approval from the board in order to move it to the U.S. Department of Education.
Thank you so much, Heather and Shiloh and all of our California colleagues up and down the state. It was really wonderful to both get that thorough explanation and to get those inspiring examples from the field.
I particularly appreciate the surviving to thriving metaphor that really speaks to us. We want to open the phone line for the public comment queue.
So, if you could put up the public comment slide, that would be helpful. Thank you. And members of the public wishing to provide comments on the item can do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that's shown now.
And while we're waiting for members of the public to call in, I want to ask Vice President Strauss, our special education liaison, if she has any initial comments. And then I'll ask if there are any clarifying questions before we go to public comment.
So, Vice President Strauss. Okay. So, Heather and Shiloh, thank you so much for the thorough presentation that explained the process. I do think adding all the additional presenters with the work around the state really brings the theory to practice as to what we're trying to do.
And I think we realize how important full, inclusive, effective practices are for our students with disabilities and all of our students. And I just so appreciate, particularly when you look at where the grant allocations are, they're far north, they're in the far south, they're in the center part of our state.
We're a really big, diverse state. And I so appreciate hearing the voices of what you are doing in early childhood education, collaborating with teachers and leaders to really change culture and practice. And really, we're changing a whole system here.
And I just so appreciate the process that the state is engaged in. It's a big shift to move. And I think investing in capacity and training clearly is what we need to do statewide. I do appreciate the identification of when districts were identified for differentiated assistance.
I think Heather said it was 60 percent of the districts were identified in the special education subgroup. And so we know statewide that achievement with students with disabilities is a really critical issue.
So all in all, I think this is a thorough process. It keeps us focused on the target of improving practice for all kids and for students with disabilities.
And I think I just appreciate the coherent approach and connecting all the pieces. And for all the leaders out in the SELPAs and the districts that are doing this work, just thank you for the continued support to improve practice for special ed students.
This was reviewed at the Advisory Commission on Special Ed. Lots of good support for the practice. And I just really appreciate the entire process and the update to the board. Thank you.
Great. Are there any clarifying questions at this moment before we go to public comment? I'm not seeing any hands. So it was a very clear presentation, so we appreciate that.
Seeing no clarifying questions, let's move to public comment.
There are six people signed up for public comment. I will open the phone lines now.
Good morning, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute and your time starts now.
Good morning. My name is Crystal Diaz and I am with Californians Together. As an organization representing English learners, we want to ensure that students receive the support they need and are appropriately identified for those supports.
It is for this reason that we encourage the State Board of Education to encourage stronger monitoring by local education agencies and the proportionality of ELs and other subgroups identified as dyslexic to their percentage of the total student population.
This information can help LEAs reflect on the efficiency of their identification and intervention strategies. Thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute and your time starts now.
Good morning, caller. Are you there?
Yes. For me?
Yes. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute and your time starts now.
Carla Herrera.
Good morning. I'm Carla Herrera, a biliteracy educator and advocate for over 45 years and former IQC member.
As past vice chair of the subject matter committee during the framework development, I appreciate that you have heard and heeded suggestions on the literacy plan for children to become literate and fluent, including and especially English learners.
However, I'm alarmed and concerned about the notion of universal. I'm sorry. Yes, this is for this is for we're currently taking public comment for item three, and I believe you would like to speak to towards item four.
If you could just call you could call back in a little while. Thank you. My apologies. Thank you. Bye bye.
Good morning. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute and your time starts now.
That looks like that concludes public comment. We had a couple callers hang out.
You're probably waiting for the next item. So, so I'd be glad to make a motion to approve the CD recommendation.
Okay, we can take a second and then have further discussion. So is there a second on that motion? I think it's member Rodriguez. Thank you. And now is there further discussion?
I remember Rodriguez. Did you have a comment?
Oh, you're on mute.
Yes, thank you. Thank you so much for the wonderful presentation I love the statewide coordination to support inclusion.
And I would also like to congratulate Dr. Trina betters, who was one of our presenters today. She was just recognized as a woman of the year for the California 23rd Senate district.
So congratulations, Dr. Better. That is an accomplishment that's well deserved because you are you do amazing work.
So congrats.
Great. Thank you. And is there any further discussion of the motion?
I am. Oh, member Navo.
I just had a quick comment and quick two questions for the group. Obviously, I approve of the motion. I think I want to thank CD for doing such a wonderful job of explaining this. It was very clear.
You took something that's oftentimes very complicated and moved us through the process very easily in a way that is understandable and comprehensible. I appreciate that.
And appreciate our stakeholders who came in and shared as well, incredibly valuable information for the field to hear what's going on. There's so much work happening around LRE and inclusive opportunities for students with disabilities.
My question is this. Maybe this is maybe for Heather and Shiloh, the first question. To what extent do you do you think that LRE will become a bigger part of the accountability conversation beyond just the ESSEP?
And then maybe for Kevin and Mindy and Kristen, to what extent is the training that you're doing leading to conversations around UDL?
Thank you, board member Navo. In terms of the conversation of least restrictive environment, it is one that is always a topic that's on the table and is something that as CDE and LEAs look at our models of continuous improvement, wanting to always ensure that our students are afforded access and maximum access to the extent possible.
And really looking at some of our LRE indicator data across the state, roughly 58% of our students are educated in a setting that puts them in a regular classroom at least 80% of the day.
18% are in a regular classroom at least 40% of the day and so on and so forth. And so really looking at the ways in which we can continue to provide that access, provide meaningful access for our students, I think will always be on the table and always be just a cornerstone of IDEA in terms of really providing that free, appropriate public education in an environment that will allow that student to grow.
And not only grow, but also thrive. And that's really the goal. And so it is something that LRE cannot be solved in a day. And so really for us, it's an ongoing effort to really ensure, as stated before, that we are continuing to really push the envelope and really explore.
Really, again, providing innovative ways and access and exploring alternate pathways and pathways to success for our students.
Thank you, Heather.
And Board Member Navo, the Universal Design for Learning is central to our work on many levels. We've worked, up in Humboldt specifically, a year and a half ago before COVID, our team provided a day and a half in-person professional development opportunity for all the districts in the state.
And we've been working with all the districts in Humboldt County around Universal Design for Learning. If you visit our website also, you'll see that we contract with Katie Novak and Andra Tisha Fritzgerald to provide Universal Design for Learning around equity and anti-racism.
Knowing that UDL cannot stay in the realm of special education, it has to be a tier one universal level of support.
Our work is always focused on ensuring that general education teachers, site administrators, district administrators, as well as special education and related staff are availed to the opportunities that Universal Design for Learning provides around equitable outcomes and access for students.
Yeah, and Member Navo, thank you, Kevin. I'm just going to piggyback on that because what's great about this whole system of collaboration and improving outcomes for students, all students, not just students with disabilities, is, you know, Kevin and Kristen and their team come in and provide really quality training and resources and ongoing support.
And then through the SELPA office, through the County Office of Education, through the member districts of the SELPA, we can provide that coaching boots on the ground and follow up with Kristen and Kevin as resources as an educational leadership team.
So it's not the old traditional professional development, one and you're done. You know, go to a workshop and then put a book on a shelf. That is no longer how we're doing business and education.
We truly are partnering in collaboration and with the SELPAs providing the ongoing coaching through our state's state grants such as CAPTN and SIPP.
And Member Navo, just a note about UDL in general, that this goes back to what Kevin was sharing earlier in that this is an adult and systems readiness model. This is not a student readiness model.
So implementing UDL as a framework is not a toolkit. It's not a new curriculum that you purchase and disseminate and is hugely costly.
But you know, this is about learner variability from the outset and us as the educators and the adults doing the work behind the scenes to make sure that our kids are the most successful in the systems that we've created for them.
So that's the heart of UDL. And as Kevin mentioned, it really is across everything that we do when we work with our districts and every piece of professional learning.
Thank you. That's wonderful to hear.
It was, you know, UDL was called out as a priority back in 2015 with the special education task force report.
So it's so encouraging to hear that it's a priority in all of the work and you're seeing results.
So thank you, Board President Garland-Hammond for allowing me the questions.
Oh, sure. I want to add on to that. And I also see that Member Rucker is waiting, but I would like to piggyback since my question deals with this.
As you noted, I'm thrilled that the special education task force report that Mike Hurst and I got going years ago is, you know, beginning to find its way into a universal system of education rather than two separate systems,
universal design for learning and work in the least restrictive environment being a key elements of that.
I am curious to hear as we continue to try to move in this direction, what the insights from those of you who are expert in the field are with respect to the challenges we've had with credentialing and preparing teachers in special education.
California has been far behind many other states in providing access to least restrictive environment because of the credentialing system that was adopted some years ago that eliminated the expectation for general credential before earning a special credential,
which then meant that those specialists could only teach in a restricted environment.
And so that created more segregation. We've been trying to move beyond that, but we have these teacher shortages.
Two thirds of the people coming in to teach special education are not completed and in many cases have not begun any preparation to teach.
So there's a steep slope to help people learn the sophisticated practices of universal design for learning that require quite a bit of understanding of learning, development, curriculum, a wide repertoire of teaching and so on.
And I would love to hear what the advice is from those of us from those who are in the field.
I know in Humboldt, there's a new teacher residency program preparing special educators from paraprofessionals who are moving into learning to become Ed specialists.
But I'm curious about other either reflections or strategies that are emerging as we try to deal with these issues.
I think if I may, Chair Darling-Hammond, address that, and this is Mindy Fatig again, and absolutely the residency program has been fantastic in here.
As you know, we have a shortage California statewide, but especially it's difficult in our rural areas that need to attract people to the far rural parts of California.
I would say in two parts. I'm also an instructor in the special education graduate program at Humboldt State University.
I'm an adjunct professor there for the last seven years.
And we've been really working with our general education counterpart at the State University in creating a trunk of classes, which I applaud CTC and your work in order to create those new credentialing requirements that are rolling out that we all have
common trunk of classes and understanding so that we can hopefully embed UDL is not just the thing that we have to learn or do, but it really is a culture and a mindset.
And in that for our teachers that we have now in the shortage, we're finding what's really effective is bringing in Kristen and Kevin and Patty and the captain work and really not just working with students who traditionally teach students with disabilities.
But we are all in this together as one system, and we need to do our professional training together.
We need to collaborate together because these are all of our kids.
And so moving forward, I think the CTC credentialing is going to significantly help in our efforts of we are all here together serving kids.
And in the meantime, the work that the state grants have been doing locally with boots on the ground and creating that shift in cultural mindset.
We've seen drastic differences in engagement from both the special educators and the general educators in providing quality UDL strategies for all students.
So I hope that addressed your questions from my perspective. Thanks.
I think in addition to that, the supporting inclusive practices projects works really closely with the Institutes of Higher Education and providing statewide training.
Last May, we provided a universal design for learning training for student teachers as well as their supervisors and created a padlet of activities for student teachers who are unable to get their student teaching requirements met in the classroom setting.
As well as working closely with the CSU system, Dominguez Hills, UC Davis to ensure that universal design for learning is a framework that is part of the teacher training process.
And then we've also created an alignment chart between the TPEs and universal design for learning resources that's available to any student teachers or supervisors across the state.
That is great.
And I do know that the governor's budget includes more resources for both teacher residencies and for Golden State teaching scholarships for special educators, as well as teachers in other shortage fields.
So we may be able to, with all of these efforts, turn the corner on this, but it's just a terrifically important area of work for us.
We really appreciate your educating us about it this morning.
And President Darling-Hammond, if I may add, this is Patty Matheny in the East Valley SELFA. If I can share my personal perspective, as well as professional perspective, I came up in the early 1980s.
And in order to get a special education credential at that time, I also had to have a general education teaching credential.
And so I learned my pedagogy, I learned curriculum, I learned instruction in those classes, and I learned then how to modify and accommodate students with special needs via my special education credential.
And so what I saw happening in the last 20 to 30 years is we moved away from that, right?
And so our current special education teachers, and this is where the change of mindset is the work we are doing in my region, truly believe they are not prepared to work with our students who have special needs.
And that's far from the truth. They have good basic instruction skills, they understand curriculum, they understand pedagogy, but we have created this silo system.
And most of it was a result of the credentialing system to somehow help them to believe they can't do so.
And I think a lot of our work needs to be done with our current teachers who have that belief.
And if we can change that vision and work to have them understand the important value they provide to students with disabilities, I think we will help to move this needle.
Thank you. Appreciate it.
Member Rucker?
Thank you. Good morning to everyone.
And I so appreciate and I always look forward to this particular presentation from the division to talk about not only the SSP, but the multiple dimensions for accountability.
I'm actually glad, Dr. Darling-Hammond, to follow your question.
When we talk about accountability, particularly in the special education system, we're actually looking at three dimensions almost at the same time.
First, we're looking at accountability to report status and data points about the performance of the program on meeting a particular state.
Second, we're looking at accountability to report student outcomes.
And that third piece is what you touched on, which was about the teacher credentialing or about the professional preparation of educators.
In a former life, I taught in the special education department at Sac State, and I taught those methods courses to special ed teachers.
So I'm always concerned when I hear that there seems to be a gap in the preparation of education professionals.
I think that what Dr. Brooks said about the purpose of these systems and the work that we're doing is about addressing the development and the work of the adults.
Students to support the performance and improvement of the students.
So I become concerned when accountability discussions about special ed starts to focus in the state performance report about the percentage of students
and how much general education or mainstreaming they're actually receiving rather than whether or not in the overall arc of the program,
we are actually delivering the program in a way that best meets the needs of the students.
So what I appreciated most from the presentation you all focused on today was the focus you provided to us about the overall outcomes,
not whether or not the work that districts are doing to meet the performance goal actually interferes with what should be placement decisions about the best needs of the students.
So what I appreciate is in the way that you all have described the work of yourself as you are still continuing to focus on not just doing the work to address the performance goal,
but to ensure that through the tools like the universal designs for learning and the other actions that you're providing in the professional development,
that the focus remains on ensuring that the programs deliver the best support and services to meet the needs of the students in the program.
So this is accountability is really more an adult issue and an adult program performance issue than whether or not the students are placed to meet a professional performance goal.
So I really appreciate the way that you all carefully explain and drew that distinction.
Thank you. I think member Glover Woods had a hand up.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond and good morning to everyone.
And thank you so much for just a very comprehensive and thorough presentation.
I'm just excited to see many of you who presented today.
I did have a question or maybe even more of a statement as it relates to LRE and percentages of students that are able to benefit from being in a more inclusive practices environment.
So my wondering is, as it relates to the data, has there been opportunity to see how those that might be in more of a least restrictive environment or those that are in more inclusive classrooms,
how that plays out as it relates to our unduplicated people groups or student groups that have been disproportionately represented in special education or even geographically when we think about our districts that might be more urban or suburban or rural.
I just wonder, again, knowing the benefit that those environments have for many students, how that plays out for students from different student groups as well as, again, geographically across our state.
If it's not data that we've been looking at as of yet, I can definitely understand that.
And just encourage us to perhaps start to look at that as well as we continue moving forward with these important projects.
And thank you again so much for sharing this morning.
Thank you, Board Member Glover-Woods. I can speak a little bit to that.
So under the requirements in the NIDEA, we are required to look at disproportionality by placement.
And so least restrictive environment is one of those areas.
And so that really breaks down both race and ethnicity inside of a number of different categories for disproportionality.
And so that is something we have been examining and as part of both of our one year and three year calculation of disproportionality over the last several years.
So I think we have looked at it and we've seen some very interesting things.
We obviously see students of color who are typically in more restrictive placements.
And I don't think that is a surprise based on our disproportionality discussions from January.
So that is sort of a trend we are seeing.
And I think the work that we're doing both with our equity project through the self-help content leads and through our TA provider SPP TAP is beginning to address some of those issues.
I notice a key area. As far as regional or even by disability, we have begun to kind of look at that.
And I will tell you how we're looking at it. And it will be interesting as we move forward.
So we're coming to the end of our six year APR cycle and we are going to need to set new targets.
And so with our stakeholder group, we did look at I believe by disability and I think regionally.
And we're going to come back to you all in the fall to kind of walk through the targeting process that we set forth with the stakeholder group and look at some of that data.
So we can bring back some of that data around least restricted environment because we will need to set targets that are approved by this board for submission to the U.S. Department of Education this fall.
So we will be bringing that data to you for you to see.
Terrific. Thank you.
I think we have probably not exhausted our questions, but answered enough of them for the moment.
And so we really appreciate this presentation. It gives us a chance to really learn about and talk about something we all care very much about.
We have a motion on the table. We have a second for that motion.
And if there's no further discussion, I will ask Brooks to call the roll for a vote.
Member Sun.
Aye.
Vice President Strauss.
Yes.
Member Rucker.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Fetillo-Brownson.
Member Navo.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Fatah.
President Darling-Hammond.
Yes.
Member Burr.
Aye.
Motion carries.
All right.
With that, and because we are moving expeditiously, we've earned a 15-minute break.
So get a cup of coffee, whatever you need.
And we will see you back here.
Oh, let's be really generous and say 10 after 10.
17 whole minutes.
Woohoo!
See you soon.
Don't leave the room.
Just turn off your video and your microphone.
Brooks, could you please call the roll?
Of course.
Member Sun.
I apologize.
I was on mute.
Here.
No problem.
Vice President Strauss.
Here.
Member Rucker.
Member Rodriguez.
Here.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Navo.
Here.
Member McQuillan.
Member Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Fatah.
President Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Burr.
We have a quorum.
Thank you.
Okay.
We're going to move on to item four.
Item four is the Comprehensive Literacy State Development Grant.
Here before us for approval.
The CDE recommends that the State Board approve the State Literacy Plan pending State Board
Executive Director approval of any final revisions requested by the SBE in correction
of any typographical errors, and this item will be presented by Barbara Murchison of
the CDE.
Nice to see you again, Barbara.
Please begin.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond, Chief Deputy Gregson, Board Members.
I'm Barbara Murchison, Director of the Educator Excellence and Equity Division at the CDE.
And today it is my pleasure to present to you California's Comprehensive State Literacy
Plan.
Get going and share my screen.
And there we are.
So as President Darling-Hammond mentioned, today we are presenting the plan to you for
approval.
The CDE recommends that the State Board of Education approve the State Literacy Plan,
but we made sure that the recommendation included some flexibility for us to be able to take
any final revisions you request today and integrate them into the plan, and then we'll
work with the Executive Director to make those changes and, of course, tidy up anything that
we might find before making it officially approved.
So as a reminder, the Comprehensive Literacy State Development Grant was an opportunity
that we applied for back in June 2019, and we were awarded about $37.5 million later
that year.
The primary goal of this federal grant program is to improve literacy instruction for children
and youth, birth through grade 12.
As part of the program, states are asked to develop, revise, or update their Comprehensive
Literacy Plans, so today we will be hopefully fulfilling one of the primary objectives of
the federal grant program.
The program also provides states with the ability to provide targeted subgrants to
local educational agencies or LEAs to implement evidence-based programs to ensure high quality
literacy instruction.
We propose to do three things in our application.
First, we propose to establish dedicated staff within the CDE to coordinate the state's efforts
around literacy over the life of the project.
We've already hired one CDE staff member to work on this grant full-time, and we've identified
two others who are working on the grant halftime as California's in-kind contribution.
These staff have already established structures to support ongoing collaboration and information
sharing around all of the department's literacy efforts, including monthly literacy roundtables
at the CDE, so that all of us who are working on various literacy initiatives can share
what we're doing and ensure that our efforts are aligned and we're aligning various projects
as we can and potentially collaborating on some of them as appropriate.
We also meet monthly with our key partners, the California Subject Matter Project, California
County Superintendents Educational Services Association, Region 15 Comprehensive Center
at West Ed, and First 5 California to similarly share updates and brainstorm ideas around
how we can improve student literacy achievement.
The CDE staff supporting this literacy grant work will also have a much larger role in
coordinating the work of the subgrantees once we move to that stage of implementation later
this year.
Our second objective, we propose to develop and implement an evidence-based comprehensive
state literacy plan that would align and integrate state literacy initiatives, the
content standards, and our various guidance documents to support educators who are teaching
students and children from birth through grade 12.
So that plan developed with stakeholders over the course of more than a year is why I'm
here today.
And third, we propose to build local capacity to establish, align, and implement local literacy
initiatives that emphasize family and community involvement to address the needs of California's
most vulnerable children.
So that's the next stage of the work.
So I'm here talking to you about the plan today, but the vast majority of the funding
that California received will go to providing professional learning for teachers to help
them improve student achievement in literacy.
95% of the literacy grant funds, more than $35.5 million, will be subgranted to local
educational agencies for that purpose.
I'll talk a little bit more about those grants and how the plan will guide them in a minute.
So the purpose of this plan is really to align and integrate state literacy initiatives,
content standards, and guidance documents to support teachers of students birth through
grade 12.
It is not meant to establish new guidance on curriculum or instruction in literacy.
California has formal processes in place to develop guidance on curriculum instruction,
and we certainly didn't want to get sideways with any of that.
The plan also does not include tools or templates.
These are going to be housed, well, some of them are already housed.
I'm excited to share with you today where we are housing resources, tools, and templates,
our new online literacy resource repository.
The plan is also designed to support continuous improvement of local literacy programs by
bringing coherence to the wealth of guidance, policies, resources, and systems that California
has in place to improve instruction and student achievement in literacy.
So we know from our needs assessments and our ongoing work to support literacy instruction
that many of our colleagues in the field are either unaware of the resources available to them
or have difficulty accessing them or challenged to understand how all of the elements might
work together.
There is a lot going on in California and trying to keep track of it to think about how the
various resources and policies and initiatives can work together to improve what's happening in
a classroom is challenging, particularly for people who are running classrooms in schools and
districts all day.
So we felt it was really important to try and bring that all together for folks in one place.
Our plan, of course, relies very heavily on California's common core state standards for
English language arts and literacy and our groundbreaking 2014 ELA-ELD curriculum framework,
but it also organizes a variety of other key documents and policies such as the English Learner
Roadmap Policy and the California Dyslexia Guidelines into a comprehensive literacy framework.
Finally, the plan models a continuous improvement process consistent with the continuous improvement
process that districts have been using to improve local outcomes and to inform their local control
and accountability plans.
So we wanted to make sure that our process was consistent with the process that our LEAs are
already using to think about continuous improvement.
So it's been a bit of a road.
About a year ago we convened a group of 35 literacy experts to serve on the state literacy team.
Members include teachers, school district and county office leaders, representatives from
professional associations, and multiple representatives with literacy expertise from higher education.
Additionally, one member each from the State Board of Education, the Commission on Teacher
Credentialing, and the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence were included on the
team to ensure that multiple state policy experts were on hand to help inform the conversation.
The team engaged in an accelerated version of the start of the continuous improvement process,
discussing goals, reviewing data, and evaluating evidence-based literacy strategies to determine
which ones might be best applied to address our identified areas of need.
After that meeting, CDE staff took the team's input to create a working draft of the plan.
Later that summer, we brought them back together for another two days to gather feedback on the updated draft.
After that second meeting of the literacy team, we made additional revisions to the draft and then
brought the plan to the Instructional Quality Commission for its feedback and to open up a formal
public comment period.
In November, we brought the public comments and our recommended revisions to the plan based on
that comment to the IQC for approval.
The IQC approved our recommendations and we updated the draft accordingly.
We presented that draft to you at your January meeting and received additional feedback from both you and
stakeholders.
We've integrated that feedback into the latest draft that we're bringing to you for approval today.
So this version, crafted over a course of more than a year and with input from hundreds of literacy
experts and stakeholders from across the state, is what we are asking you to approve.
So I feel like I need to take a moment to express my gratitude to the state literacy team, an amazing group of
individuals, our partners both within and beyond the CDE, and everyone who made the time to provide public
comments on the plan during the past year.
All of these contributions have really strengthened the document.
I also want to take a moment to thank the members of the educator excellence and equity team who have
been working on this plan and grant implementation for the past year.
Aline, Allison, Zaria, Jennifer, Joy, and Erica.
Creating a state plan is exciting because it presents multiple opportunities to talk to a lot of different
people to learn more about what's really important to them.
And it's often an exercise in balancing what is required with what is possible.
And then working to organize all of that into a document that will actually be helpful to people.
We experienced all of that with this plan.
But since it was developed entirely online, this document presented a myriad of new challenges and
opportunities to do things differently along the way.
Aline, Jen, Joy, and Erica repeatedly rose to the occasion to create this document and to do a lot of
other really exciting work around this grant.
So many thanks to them for their hard work and innovative spirit throughout this last year.
A quick reminder regarding how the plan is organized.
We've got an executive summary providing a high-level overview of what's included.
And then the introduction includes background information on the federal grant program, the purpose
and logic model, a section on how to read the plan, and information about California's diverse student
population.
Then we get into the body of the document.
Comprehensive and integrated literacy model helps us to meet our purpose of aligning and integrating
state literacy resources and initiatives in order to demonstrate how they're connected and can be
used in a coherent way.
Really, this section of the plan identifies resources as defining both what best first instruction is or
as how these various resources can support best first instruction.
The continuous improvement process section of the plan, which is a great deal of the document, goes
through each step of the continuous improvement process that the CDE used with its partners to assess
statewide literacy needs and develop a plan to leverage the grant funds to address those needs.
It also includes a work cited section and a few appendices, including a glossary, data tables, and
additional assessment results.
So thank you again to you and the stakeholders who provided additional feedback on the document in
January.
We've taken that feedback and used it to update this draft of the plan.
First, to clarify the comprehensive approach to English language development put forth in all of
California's guidance documents, we've updated language throughout the plan in the statewide priorities to
replace English language instruction with comprehensive English language development.
Just to be very clear, when we're talking about English language instruction, we're talking about all of
the themes in the framework.
We also heard the concerns expressed around the section describing universal screening.
We clarified the guidance on universal screening, including more information around appropriate timing
and precautions around potential misdiagnosis of disabilities.
I think this is a good time to reiterate that this plan does not contain any mandates or processes that
schools are required to implement.
These are recommendations that we've pulled from existing guidance documents.
Consistent with continuous improvement process, we will be revisiting this plan regularly over the
course of the grant and will update the guidance within both around universal screening as new
guidance becomes available.
And with other things, we anticipate that we'll have a new framework somewhere in the midst of our
grant implementation.
So at that point, we will revisit the plan and make some adjustments as necessary.
We also strengthen the language in the asset-based pedagogy section, including acknowledging widening
achievement gaps and the value of culturally sustaining pedagogy, in particular for communities of
color, and we added language to the grade 6-12 statewide priority section regarding structured
literacy interventions for older students.
A lot of board conversation in January revolved around what our subgrantees would be expected to do,
so we took that feedback and updated the plan to provide a bit more clarity on that topic.
So all grantees will be required to implement programs aligned to the comprehensive and integrated
literacy model, which means leveraging all the key themes in the ELA-ELD framework and all strands of
the Common Core for ELA literacy.
All of the grantees will be required to support teacher understanding and implementation of
culturally relevant and sustaining pedagogies, and will also support implementation of evidence-based
family literacy strategies.
And consistent with our federal grants objectives, all grantees will be required to focus on the needs
of historically underserved students, including children living in poverty, English learners,
children with disabilities, and children of color.
Grantees will also support LEAs to develop and implement local literacy plans, will be required to
define, measure, and report relevant metrics, and will be expected to make appropriate course
adjustments if defined metrics are not being met.
So we will ensure that all of that is very clearly outlined in the request for applications that we
hope to release relatively soon.
So consistent with federal requirements, again, we're going to have seven, we're hoping to select,
we're planning, we're not hoping, we're planning to select seven local literacy lead agencies across
the state.
This will be county offices.
Consistent with federal requirements, the birth through age five lead will receive 15% of the funding.
There will be one lead for that group of students or children.
The three transitional kindergarten to grade five leads will receive 40% of the funding, and the
three grade six to grade 12 leads will receive 40% of the funding.
Subgrants to the local literacy lead agencies will support the implementation and study of evidence
based strategies to address the statewide literacy priorities identified in the plan and support the
literacy needs of economically disadvantaged and high need students.
To be very clear, the comprehensive literacy state development grant priority, and this is the federal
priority and our priority as well, is improving student outcomes by improving classroom instruction.
Subgrantees are going to have some latitude in their applications to describe which evidence based
strategies they will leverage to improve literacy instruction for the particular group of students
that they're serving and for the particular priority they want to go deep with, but ultimately providing
high quality teacher professional learning to improve classroom instruction is the focus of this grant.
Seven county offices are going to be selected to do this deep work around the priorities in the plan, and
the CDE is going to elevate what they learn and the resources they develop to the statewide system of
support so that everyone has access to the information that they are learning.
So at this point, I want to share with you some of the resources the CDE has already developed or collected
to support professional development and professional learning around literacy instruction statewide.
We call our big objective here, beyond the plan and beyond creating some coherence by bringing on a couple
of additional staff, is really to build state and local capacity to support high quality literacy
instruction. So as promised, we have been building out a literacy resources repository in a new space
called California Educators Together. I'm going to cross my fingers, Zoom willing, I'll get us to the site.
It's just been up for a few days. So once we get there, we'll see some interesting things, I'm sure.
Last time we were together, I mentioned that we were building out sets of videos with our state literacy team.
Our state literacy team had volunteered to help us come up with evidence-based resources.
Let's see if we can get there this way. If not, we'll try and get there another way.
All right. So hopefully you can see we are loading California Educators Together.
Can you all see this on your screen? All right. I'm going to keep going. If you can't see it, let me know.
Here's our brand spanking new California Educators Together literacy resources repository.
And you can get to this from our main comprehensive literacy state development grant web page.
I'll have a reminder of how to get there in a bit. But you can see we've started to compile some.
I think it's not showing on our screens, Barbara. OK, let me try another way.
I'm still seeing your slide. Thank you for letting me know. I'm going to try another way.
Because I would have just kept talking. All right, now you can see it. Can you not?
Thank you. I see member Rucker nodding. Thank you. All right.
So here we are at our brand new literacy resources repository.
And I'm just going to show you a couple of highlights and encourage you and anyone else who's interested in using all of these cool things after our time together.
But you can see we've organized things in a variety of ways. First, we have our birth through age five resources.
Then we've got our transitional kindergarten through grade five resources.
Then we've got our grade six through twelve resources. So we've organized them in collections by grade band, because, again, this grant is is organized by grade bands.
And what I want to do is just go into the birth through age five resource collections just a bit so you can take a look at how we've got that together.
You can see we've got a collection of resources to support assessment practices, a collection around asset based pedagogy, a collection around best first instruction,
a collection around family community engagement, professional learning and coaching, supporting English learners, supporting students with disabilities and students who are struggling to read.
So these are all priorities that are called out in the grant document. So I was a little nervous when I'm sharing new collections in real time.
But even, you know, and again, these resources have been curated by the state literacy team either suggested or reviewed and curated to be of high quality to make sure because we know that managing resources is a challenge for folks.
So much out there. So we wanted to make sure that what we were offering was looked at pretty closely reviewed by the state literacy team and CDE staff.
So in our asset based pedagogy collection for the birth through age five grade band, you can see there are a couple of articles, there are documents, there are websites.
I know it's a huge priority to us to think in particular around, you know, how are we supporting our students with from African American backgrounds.
And you can see we've we've with an eye for that. There are a few resources just in here for the zero to five group focused just on that.
See if I can get back supporting English learners for the zero to five group. We've got another collection.
And there are just a couple of resources in there. Again, just getting started wanting to make sure that what we offer in this website is is looked at closely and we believe it to be evidence based and of high quality.
So I'm not going to click on all of these things because you've got a busy day.
But I just wanted to give you a little preview of how we've got those collections for those grade spans.
Last time we were together I told you we were working with our state literacy team to build out this knowledge building video series.
This one's just the intro, but I want to show you this one.
Dr. Marianne Wolf, who is the director of UCLA Center for Dyslexia, Diverse Learners and Social Justice and kind of an international expert on dyslexia and how students learn how to read, also is a member of our state literacy team.
We've got a couple of resources in there.
I don't put together who most of the
But you know, the California dyslexia initiative
is getting up and running.
But you know, the California dyslexia initiative is getting
And there's ongoing work.
There's ongoing work.
I believe the educator workforce investment without
I believe the educator workforce investment grant
for special education also focuses on dyslexia.
So People have questions about how all of this
and I anticipate that this will be a place
where we can share resources
from across all of those initiatives.
So here you have a rather large collection
of videos around integrated and designated ELD
developed by the California Department of Education.
And it's quite a lovely series
broken down by various grades
around how you can support English language development.
And these two collections
are from the Educator Workforce Investment Grant.
So our colleagues at CAST have been doing that work
and they have been creating materials.
We have them in our Knowledge Building Collection as well.
So again, there's a lot to see here.
It is in development.
I think you may be the very first public showing
of California Educators Together
and certainly the first showing
of our new literacy resources collection.
That's the last thing I wanna show you here
because we did hear from folks, the state plan looks fine.
How does this work for local educational agencies?
And I was like, oh, we're working on that.
The way we're working on that
is we've built out this local literacy planning toolkit.
So that is also on California Educators Together.
And this toolkit is
designed to help LEAs
think about their own literacy planning
in a way that's aligned to the state literacy plan.
The toolkit will also be
on the California Department of Education webpages
so people can find it there as well.
As we mentioned, our subgrantees
will be supporting districts in their regions
to do some literacy planning of their own.
And this is not required that people use these materials,
but we built out this set of tools
so that folks can build
can engage in a continuous improvement process
around literacy in a way that's parallel
to how we have done it at the state
to build our literacy plan.
So with that, oh, I forgot to show you one more thing,
but I'll just tell you at the very bottom
of the collection,
we do have a set of research articles
that we've asked our colleague, Dr. Linda Friedrich,
who is the Director of Literacy at WestEd
to help us identify some really high leverage
kinds of literacy research
so that we can build out kind of a library of research
around how to support literacy across the grade spans.
And we have that in a separate collection as well.
So thanks to her for helping us too.
So,
hopefully, okay, let's go PowerPoint.
Here we are.
So once the plan is approved,
we'll get to work identifying our subgrantees.
We will continue to build out resources
in our resources repository in a continuous manner
throughout the life of the grant.
Again, as our subgrantees are learning
and building out resources,
they too will go into the repository.
But now the work begins of identifying our subgrantees.
We are planning to make that RFA available by May
and to grant the awards by September.
We want to accelerate that timeline,
potentially releasing the RFA next month
and awarding the funds in August.
But as circumstances evolve,
we continue to consider how this grant is gonna intersect
and support all of the other investments
that are happening with student literacy.
So we'd prefer to take a little more time
to think that through than to rush
to get the RFA out the door.
Right now, we're thinking about this large influx of funding
that is coming to our LEAs
from both state and federal governments
to address student learning needs
that may have intensified during the past year.
I think a lot of folks are worrying
about how to invest those funds wisely.
So we're thinking about how we might encourage
those who apply for this grant opportunity
to braid various funding resources,
to amplify or expand the work
that they will be proposing to do as a local literacy lead.
But again, our guiding principle here,
we are driven to ensure that our literacy efforts
are coherent and evidence-based.
So here's just a little reminder
that all interested parties can find much more information
around the Comprehensive Literacy
State Development Grant Program
and information about how the plan was developed
on the CDE CLSD webpage.
This week, we added the link
to our online resources repository there.
So people who want to go into that collection and explore
can find the link there.
And as always, we encourage everyone to join our listserv
to stay looped in as the work continues.
And if anyone has questions about the grant at any point,
our email is clsdp at cde.ca.gov.
So with that, here is our recommendation.
Today, we are seeking your approval of the plan,
pending final approval of the board executive director
of any revisions that you might request today.
At this time, I'd be happy to respond
to any questions you might have.
Thank you so much.
We're going to get ready to queue up for public comment.
Then we'll ask clarifying questions,
then we'll hear comments and come back for discussion.
So here is the public comment information
and we'll open that queue.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
may call the telephone number
and use the access code provided on the slide.
And while we're waiting for members of the public
to call in, I'll ask Vice President Strauss
as our liaison, if she has any initial comments.
And then we'll see if there are any clarifying questions
before we turn to public comment.
So let me just say, this has been a really thoughtful,
long process that began at the end of March,
just as we had the shutdown in 2020.
So as Barbara said, this was done completely remotely.
And from the beginning, it has been,
the team has been so thoughtful, so thorough.
And I just have to commend Barbara and the CDE team
for being open to the diverse stakeholder inputs.
My understanding from all the stakeholders
is that CDE has been listening,
they've updated the plan and has been very responsive.
And I think it's really exciting to see,
and I appreciate that districts
are going to be getting other funding,
but $35 million to continue our work statewide
to improve literacy for students
and improve capacity is very exciting.
I appreciated Barbara sharing with us the website
with the modules and the videos,
which I think will continue to support educators.
And while this only goes to seven county offices
that will then work with districts,
I think it has benefits of our long-term commitment
to improving teacher capacity
to support literacy throughout the state.
And I appreciated some focus on designated ELD
as well as integrated ELD,
which is a highlight of our ELA ELD framework,
but we know still needs continued support of teachers
to have the right strategies.
So again, I so appreciate it.
And I just want to remind everyone,
there's no new requirements in this plan,
and there's no funding conditions for LEAs
to benefit from support from the literacy lead agencies.
I also appreciate the coordination
that the role of CDE will do in this process,
and just appreciate the thorough process
to get this plan as a guidance document
to improve literacy for all of our students.
Thank you.
Great, and it's also very exciting to see the new website.
So thank you for sharing that as well.
Really great to see that.
Are there any clarifying questions from members of the Board
before we go to public comment?
I'm not seeing any hands.
Therefore, we'll see if we have public commenters.
There are currently 18 people signed up
in the queue for public comment.
I will open the phone lines now.
Good morning, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, State Board of Education.
Go ahead.
Go ahead, caller.
Meagan Potente, Meagan Potente,
Co-State Director for Decoding Dyslexia, California.
The language added on pages 86 through 90
wrongly conflates special education eligibility
with screening for risk of dyslexia.
The goal of screening is not to diagnose dyslexia
as a risk of dyslexia,
but to address dyslexia as a risk of dyslexia.
Screening is not to diagnose students with dyslexia.
Screening identifies students who may be at risk
of experiencing difficulty with reading
and may need more instruction.
This is made clear in the ELA ELD framework
and the California Dyslexia Guidelines
that the paragraphs added to the SLP confuse screening
with evaluation for special education eligibility.
Describing exclusionary criteria under which a student
may not be considered as having a learning disability
is not relevant where it was added to the SLP.
Including this language here sends the message
that students need special ed eligibility
before they can access targeted reading support,
which is counter to federal and state guidance
on early intervention.
DDCA does not support the addition to the SLP as described.
Thank you, caller, your time is up.
Good morning, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Rachel Heard
and I am a school board member.
Goodbye.
Go ahead, caller.
We get her back.
You're live.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Good morning, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
We're having some phone difficulties at the moment.
We are going to take a quick break here
while we get that situated.
We just need one moment to reconnect the phone line.
We will simply wait.
Okay.
Good morning, caller.
Are you there?
Hello?
Hi, you're live.
Please go ahead and state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute and your time starts now.
I am Lori DePole.
Students with dyslexia are general education students first
and the majority of them will not be found eligible
for special education services.
In MTSS, universal screening occurs in tier one
as a critical first step
to early identification of students
who are at risk and who may need more instruction.
The newest change to the state literacy plan
made under universal screening on pages 86 to 87
and 89 to 90 confuse special education eligibility
and the exclusionary factors
in determining special education eligibility
with universal screening.
ESSA requires screening of all students
under a comprehensive literacy plan
and does not require sped eligibility
or sped exclusionary factors as a further hurdle
for determining students who are at risk
and need appropriate early MTSS intervention.
We respectfully request that this language be removed
as it is misleading and it does not align
with state adopted ELA ELG framework
regarding universal screening
or the California dyslexia guidelines.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute and your time starts now.
Good morning, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute and your time starts now.
My name is Rachel Heard and I'm a school board member.
It's frustrating to hear that despite so much talk
about the importance of early intervention, RTI, MTSS,
so many students who need help with foundational skills
don't get the help they need until they're years behind
and the most opportune and efficient time
for intervention for them is gone.
It's critical that the concept of universal screening
in this plan be clearly separated
from formal assessment for special education
to avoid the continued confusion expressed
by some other callers who are advocating
for Californians together.
It needs to be clear what universal screening is
and is not for.
It also needs to be clear to anyone using this plan
that students with dyslexia can and should be served
in general education.
Certainly, some may need federal education,
but the irony and reality is that many who don't qualify
for special ed end up in a no man's land of need
with no help at all.
I urge you to approve the plan,
but please remove the language that has been.
Thank you, caller, your time is up.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Martha Hernandez,
the Executive Director of Californians Together.
I would like to thank Barbara Murchison,
the committee and CD staff
for incorporating stakeholder input and feedback.
There are numerous positive updates
and feedbacks that we've been receiving
from the board of directors,
there are numerous positive updates to the plan
and are very appreciative of the improvements made
since the January state board meeting,
including but not limited to the updated language
and the statewide priorities
to replace English language instruction
with comprehensive English language development.
The clarification that each grantee,
regardless of statewide priority focus,
will be required to implement programs
that integrate all five key literacy themes
of the ELA ALD framework.
The stronger language in the assets-based pedagogy section,
including acknowledging the value of culturally
and linguistically responsive teaching
and clarification regarding guidance
on universal screening for dyslexia,
including precautions against the misdiagnosis
of disabilities for English learners.
Thank you.
Good morning, state board of education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Hi, my name is Christy Dennis
and I'm the parent of two students
with dyslexia in Los Angeles.
When my first child began school,
we had no idea that he would have trouble learning.
He was bright and sociable
and his preschool teacher told us
that he would succeed anywhere.
But only a few months into kindergarten,
we began receiving reports
that he's far behind his peers in reading.
To complicate matters, our family is fully bilingual
and he was attending a bilingual school,
so his struggles were attributed to his bilingual status
rather than identified as a learning disability.
We were repeatedly told that delays are normal
and we should just be patient.
It took five years to get him properly diagnosed
and due to that delay,
he's still far behind his peers today in high school.
Universal screening would have changed his life profoundly.
Bilingual students like my sons are just as likely
as their peers to have dyslexia
and I fear that any efforts to exclude them
from a rigorous and targeted screening process
would miss opportunities for them to get the help they need.
In fact, they are perhaps the ones most in need
of the screening because their status
as English language learners makes it more difficult
to identify their reading disabilities.
Furthermore, the method of instruction
that works for dyslexic students
also works for all students.
Thank you, Caller, your time is up.
Otherwise, it would not be advantageous.
Thank you, Caller.
State Board of Education,
name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Yes, my name is Katherine Christo,
professor emeritus at Sacramento State University.
I am concerned about additions
to the state literacy plan added this month,
particularly the paragraph inserted
into the section labeled supporting students,
subhead universal screening on page 86.
The added paragraph that begins California's regulations
pertinent to identification
of a specific learning disability
goes on to discuss qualifications for special education.
This is not relevant to the purpose of universal screening,
which is what this section is about.
The presence of this paragraph regarding special education
in this section is confusing and will lead to readers
assuming that universal screening
is a function of special ed, which it is not.
On the contrary, screening is a general ed function
and the first step in any MTSS program.
I urge the board to remove this and similar paragraphs,
which will leading them there will only contribute
to misunderstanding around the purpose
of universal screening.
Thank you, Caller, your time is up.
Strong within this document.
Good morning, State Board of Education,
please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, my name is Lynn Scott.
I'm a professor at Cal State East Bay.
My research is in early child language development
and literacy.
Moving the time for dyslexia screening
to the spring of first grade
to allow for sufficient literacy instruction
to be able to identify those students
struggling with reading is urgent.
Moving this recommendation so that it focuses on children
with special needs and children that are at risk
is what is critical in this.
Using limited instructional time and resources
for universal screening or screening of all students
will not target and benefit those most at need.
Those students who read well meet grade level
reading standards and or meet local benchmarks
or other formative reading assessments
do not need to be assessed.
Again, valuable instructional time will be lost
on assessing every student
rather than targeting those students at risk.
Thank you.
Good morning, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good morning, my name is Michelle Perry.
I'm a special education advocate
and parent of a child with dyslexia.
My comment today is regarding universal screening
for dyslexia.
We cannot continue to take a wait for them
to fail approach.
We need to catch students at risk of dyslexia
before they fail and universal screening
will help us do that.
Universal screening K through second grade
would have helped educators identify my child
and count with others for being at risk
for reading failure early on.
It also would have helped to keep skill deficits
from becoming significant achievement gaps.
Universal screening helps identify those students
who are at risk for reading failure.
Universal screening is not the same as an assessment
for special education eligibility.
No child should have to struggle in school
and suffer the negative effects of being unable to read
because we have the tool to help our students succeed.
Let's use them, thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning, state board of education,
please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
My name is Ronique Glickman
and I'm an elementary school teacher
and the mother of a daughter with dyslexia.
Universal screening is a tool to help identify students
who are at risk of reading failure
and inform instruction in the general education classroom.
A formal evaluation for special education
is not a prerequisite for this to occur.
Universal screening would have identified my daughter
early in kindergarten and informed both her teachers
and myself, saving her years of struggle
and emotional distress,
but instead I had to argue and fight with my peers
while everyone followed the status quo
of our current weight and see model.
My daughter continued to fall further
and further behind her peers.
I feel embarrassed and ashamed
that I failed to identify my own daughter
along with many other of my students,
including EL students.
A universal screening will give teachers a tool
they need to target kids at risk,
ultimately saving children or family years of struggle
and altering the trajectory of their lives.
Finally, universal screening will prevent many students
from needing special education.
Ultimately-
Caller, your time is up.
Good morning, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good morning, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Good morning, State Board of Education.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good morning, my name is Dr. Barbara Flores,
CABA President-Elect.
I have three concerns related
to the State Literacy Plan universal screening
for dyslexia.
Number one, assessing pupils in K-1
may not be developmentally appropriate.
Two, assessment for K-1 must be validated
and found statistically appropriate
that is reliable for use with pupils at this age.
If not, there may be a false positive
and false negative leading to inappropriate placement.
EL students' developmental linguistic behaviors in L2,
three, EL students' developmental linguistic behavior
in L2 may be similar to those
of dyslexic students at K-1.
If so, this will confound the results of the assessments
and lead to mislabeling and misidentification
of EL students.
Thank you.
Good morning, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Hello, I am Dr. Lucy Edwards
from Napa County Office of Education,
representing CSESA and the Curriculum
and Instruction Steering Committee, also known as CISC.
CISC submitted a detailed letter of feedback
and provided public comment to the State Board of Education
regarding the State Literacy Plan in January.
CISC wants to again acknowledge the efforts
by the various state agencies and literacy experts
that went into the development of the State Literacy Plan.
We'd also like to thank the State Board of Education
and the California Department of Education
for taking our previous comments and feedback
into consideration with the updated draft.
We appreciate that the State Literacy Plan
will leverage culturally sustaining pedagogies
across grade bands, including specifically addressing
the needs of African-American students.
As this student group has been called out in the data
as one of the lowest performing groups
over time on the CAST summative assessments.
Again, thank you for taking CISC's feedback
into consideration as guidance is urgently needed
to best support all students in literacy.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute and your time starts now.
My name is Lorraine Richards
and I am representing California Teachers Association.
CTA appreciates the CDE's efforts to put together
a comprehensive state literacy plan
that lists and organizes resources
for the state of California.
The plan does an excellent job with organizing content.
We also appreciate the clarification regarding the section
regarding screening tests for dyslexia.
While there is nothing wrong with screening in general,
the state needs to help districts be purposeful
and thoughtful in conducting the screening
and differentiating between screening and diagnosis.
CTA recommends that instead of universal screening
beginning in the spring of kindergarten,
we recommend an initial assessment at the end of grade one
or at the beginning of grade two.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
My name is Karina Sapien.
I work for SEAL and I'm here to speak
on behalf of Californians Together.
I have been a public school educator for over 30 years,
including seven years as an elementary principal.
We are asking that you consider eliminating
the recommendation that all students be screened
for dyslexia.
As a former elementary school principal,
I know that school districts and classroom teachers
have built-in assessments to regularly monitor
students' reading progress throughout the year.
This gives them useful and valid information
about who should be targeted for additional screening.
Therefore, it is not only unnecessary to screen all students,
it's a misuse of instructional time.
As we return from a year of distance learning,
all of our students will need every minute
they can get of teaching and learning.
It makes no sense to screen those students who read well,
meet grade-level reading standards,
and or meet local benchmarks
or other formative reading assessments.
Valuable instructional time will be lost
on screening every student,
and the very students we are targeting
have the most to lose.
The screening tool should be used judiciously
for those students who demonstrate that they need it
and actually stand.
Thank you, Paula, your time is up.
Thank you.
Good morning, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Good morning, my name is Dr. Anya Hurwitz,
Executive Director of SEAL,
Sabado Early Academic Language.
I share concerns with many colleagues
that a universal dyslexia screener
might have some major unintended consequences,
and I urge you to take into consideration
the essential need that this screener be valid, reliable,
and appropriate for young English learners.
I'm particularly concerned about screener administration,
and I'm elevating the critical importance
that the people administering these dyslexia screeners
would need to receive comprehensive training
to ensure deep knowledge and understanding,
especially with regards to linguistically diverse students.
If classroom teachers at the designated grade levels
would do the bulk of the screening,
it would be essential for a comprehensive,
well-defined, and fully funded plan to be created
to ensure appropriate training for those teachers.
So it is critical that we ensure
that this screener be developed to be truly valid,
reliable, and appropriate for English learners,
and that there is truly adequate professional development
for educators who would be responsible
for administering the screeners.
Thank you for your attention.
Thank you, Paula.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, and your time starts now.
Good morning, I'm Carla Herrera.
Soon to be Carla Santa Cruz this Saturday.
My apologies for my earlier preemptive timing confusion
must be wedding jitters.
As a bi-literacy educator and former ITC member,
I appreciate you have heard and heeded suggestions
to support children's language literacy
and bi-literacy development.
I also really like the electronic format of resources.
However, I'm still concerned about the notion
of a universal dyslexia screening for all children.
Do you really recommend assessing children for dyslexia
if they are already reading?
I ask that you only screen children
who may need it with these conditions.
Move the timing for dyslexia screening
to the spring of first grade
to allow for sufficient instruction time
to be able to identify those students
who are indeed struggling with reading,
and screen in the language of instruction,
taking into account the child's emerging
home language development and proficiency.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Carla, and congratulations.
Thank you.
Good morning, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute, your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Sandy Mendoza of Families and Schools
on behalf of Californians Together.
Parents want to share the child's educational journey,
which means that they need to know
what the screening tool is about
so that they can feel confident
that their child is being correctly assessed
and appropriate interventions and accommodations are offered.
In particular, parents of English learners
will want to understand what the exact nature
of the factors and criteria
is involved in the dyslexia screening process.
Every child is unique because of a multitude of factors
in and outside of school that will influence
that child's educational path and progress.
Toward that end, I ask that key considerations be given
so that the screening correctly distinguishes
between a language need and a disability.
Factors such as how much exposure the child has to English
and what percentage of time the native language
and English spoken in the home
could result in a false positive.
Thus, another consideration is to conduct a screening
in two languages, English and the child's native language.
Thank you very much for your time.
Thank you.
Good morning, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
State Board of Education,
please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hi, good morning.
My name is Manuel Bonrostro with Californians Together.
And I just wanna say that it is appreciated
that details were added regarding
the Local Literacy Lead Agencies Grant,
specifically clarifying that each grantee,
regardless of statewide priority focus,
would be required to implement programs
aligned to the comprehensive and integrated literacy model,
including integration of all key themes
of the English language arts,
English language development framework,
all strands of the California Common Core Standards
for English language arts,
and culturally relevant and sustaining pedagogies.
We also appreciate the language
about leveraging evidence-based family literacy strategies
to ensure that our families are engaged throughout,
and also making sure that there's a focus
on the needs of underserved students,
including children living in poverty,
English learners, children with disabilities,
and children of color.
Thanks again for making these changes to the grant,
and thank you for listening to our comments.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Maureen Graves.
I'm co-chair of the California Association
for Parent-Child Advocacy.
I've been representing parents
seeking special ed services since 1994,
mostly Spanish-speaking clients,
about half of whom have autism.
All my clients have literacy needs.
My own adult son's with autism,
one of whom also has intellectual disability,
learned to talk at ages two and three
with applied behavior analysis.
For them, as for many children, language was hard won,
not natural, as the state literacy plan claimed.
My sons left into decoding in a week when they were four,
when their teachers showed them the code for reading English
and have made it through the pandemic,
largely by reading fiction and nonfiction,
as their jobs are on hold.
Many of my clients were never taught to read.
Over the years, statewide documents
have helped me advocate for children.
This document departs from that proud tradition,
as explained in my written submissions in November and March.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
Martha Zaragoza Diaz,
representing the California Association
for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
We believe the universal screening for dyslexia
requires further strengthening specific to English learners.
As reflected in our letter of March 8th,
our recommendations include moving the timing
for dyslexia screening to the end of first grade
to allow for sufficient literacy instruction
to be able to identify those students struggling with reading
and eliminating the requirement that all students be assessed.
Not all students need to be screened.
Those students who read well meet grade level reading standards
and or meet local benchmark
or other formative reading assessments
do not need to be assessed.
Please revise the state plan to reflect these recommendations
and the others in our letter.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
I apologize for speaking on the wrong action item previously,
but my name is Crystal Diaz
and I am with Californians Together.
As an organization representing English learners,
we want to ensure that students receive the support
that they need and are appropriately identified
for those supports.
It is for this reason that we encourage
the State Board of Education
to encourage stronger monitoring by local educational agencies
on the proportionality of ELs and other subgroups
identified as dyslexic to their percentage
of the total student population.
This information can help LEAs reflect on the efficiency
of their identification and intervention strategies.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
Caller, are you there?
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello?
Hello.
Please speak.
Hi, my name's Michael Miller.
My daughter Layla attends Ross Valley Charter School
in Fairfax.
Oh, I'm sorry, sir?
Could you please call back?
We are currently taking public comment
for item number four.
Your item is coming up later on today.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
My name is Elvia Armas,
Director and Affiliated Faculty
at LNU Center for Equity for English Learners.
We share concerns regarding
the universal dyslexia screening
and the valid, reliable, and appropriate use
for young English learners.
We've noted the reference
to the California Practitioner's Guide
and dyslexia guidelines in the SLP,
yet urge the addition of the following to this document.
One, specific expectations for screening
and assessment processes,
including language development factors,
such as oral language skills, language proficiency,
context of use, and instructional strategy.
Two, monitoring guidelines to ensure
that black and brown children,
as well as English learners
of all ethnic and racial backgrounds,
are not overly identified as dyslexic.
We must look to the entire system
to hold ourselves accountable.
I strongly urge you to include accountability guidelines
for LEAs to develop critical checkpoints
that consider proportionality of the observed,
assessed, and identified as dyslexic
to the screening and assessment processes.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Yes, good morning.
My name is Carolina Serna.
I'm an associate professor at Biola University,
and I also sit on the board
of the California Association for Bilingual Education.
As a professor who teaches literacy development methods
for teacher candidates,
I want to express my concern regarding the recommendation
for universal screening for dyslexia.
I recommend that only students who exhibit difficulties
with emergent literacy should be screened.
Those students who read well
meet grade-level reading standards
and or meet local benchmarks
or other formative reading assessments
do not need to be assessed.
I also recommend that all multilingual students be assessed
in their native language
as well as the language of instruction.
In addition, I would like to see an expanded focus
on biliteracy in general in the plan,
as well as more inclusion of resources
in the English learner toolkit
that address biliteracy.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Yes.
Paula, are you there?
Yeah, I'm at source 12.
We can barely hear you.
If you could speak a little louder.
We can use ratio table.
Okay.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Okay.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Deborah Schlegel on behalf of CAFCA,
California Association for Parent Child Advocacy.
It is ironic that earlier today,
this group talked about inclusive practices,
yet the SLP includes, quote unquote,
natural language development
in the birth to age five literacy section.
This language is offensive and misleading
and should be removed.
Careful consideration should be given
to how it excludes a substantial number
of children with disabilities
who need specially designed instruction
like applied behavior analysis
and traditional speech and language pathology services.
This harmful language is not irrelevant.
As the IDEA reminds us,
disability is a natural part of the human experience
and in no way diminishes the right of individuals
to participate in or contribute to society.
I urge you to have an inclusion specialist
on every committee that works on projects like these.
Thank you very much for your time.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Okay.
It looks like that concludes public comment
for this item.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I want to appreciate all of the callers
for raising the range of concerns that have been raised.
I do want to start off the discussion
by sharing that when I saw some of the comment letters
come in, I did call on several of the experts
in the state who are involved in developing screeners
and want to share that several things.
First, as the parent of two dyslexic children,
I appreciate the comments about the importance
of screening early, which is not a,
as was earlier made the point,
which is not the same as establishing
special education eligibility.
I think that the language in the plan
that seems to conflate those is confusing to folks
and will probably need to be adjusted or removed.
But the two major screening efforts in the state
that are under development,
one at UCSF under the guidance
of the dyslexia center there,
Dr. Maria Luisa Giorno Tempini,
and one at UCLA under the guidance
of Dr. Marianne Wolf, who's just arrived there
in the last couple of years from Harvard University.
Both of these are efforts that one of them
with state support that are intended
to be in multiple languages,
are intended not to automatically lead
to any kind of diagnosis or placement,
but simply to provide information
on which other analyses of next steps can be taken.
And so I think that the concern about the point
of screening and the outcomes of screening
will need to be clarified in the plan
so that we don't have the expectation
that somehow we're screening students prematurely
in a language setting that is inappropriate
for somehow automatic placement in special education.
That is not a goal of screeners.
They also shared with me and I passed on to our staff
a number of articles that have been published
in the literature about the stage of screening
and the kind of learning supports for readers
that can be provided based on that information
and other information that is gathered in further analyses.
And it is clear that understanding the needs
of learners sooner at the end of kindergarten
rather than later makes a big difference
in the opportunity for that student to be well-taught
and caught up and in sync with other learners
by the end of first grade and high school.
So that's a big part of first grade and on into other grades.
So I think we do need to, as we proceed,
clarify that screeners are not disability identifiers
or placement tools.
They are information tools to be used
to then build other analyses.
And if there is a need for further diagnostics,
to flag those diagnostics to then occur.
So I will open up the floor for discussion at this point
and glad to share anything else about those conversations
if folks want to pursue that.
And member Rucker, you are first in the queue.
Thank you very much.
I listened with great interest to the comments
that came out of the public discussion
and I do have two questions or concerns
that I want to speak on briefly.
The first one's a little bit easier than the second.
This will be the second consecutive item
on today's agenda.
And every agenda we have had since I've been on the board
has always talked about looking at closing
or addressing the performance gap
of underrepresented students, of students of color
and figuring out where the priorities need to be
in providing the critical supports for students of color
and underrepresented students and English learners.
At some point in time, there needs to this priority
that the board keeps stating needs to become apparent
in the work that LEAs are doing
to address this particular group.
We continue to talk about the need
to close the performance gap and talk about the need
to make these students a priority.
Yet in this plan, we continue to state
that the LEAs receiving these grants
will identify their own local priorities.
And I'm sorry to say, oftentimes those priorities
concerning students of color, concerning English learners
are not always apparent and are not always as explicit
as what's been written in this plan.
So there does need to be some accountability
to the subgrantees, not just for the outcomes of the program
but to also think about how you hold them accountable
in the RFA to articulate how they are going
to make the students we've identified
as the priority of this grant,
the priority of the work that they will do
in the services they provide for professional learning
as well as the resources that they will be using
to provide in those classrooms to support instruction.
So that was the easier comment for me to make.
The second one is a little bit more difficult.
I rely on the expertise and the comments that I hear
from the public and from a lot of the people
that our board president spoke to about what is the best way
to deal with the idea of universal screening
and to look at the concern of dyslexia.
And the continuum is very broad.
There are very clear and very distinct differences
of opinion, not about whether or not we should be using
universal screening, but when and how and whom.
And so I think that I agree with the recommendation
that's been made to look at when the screening is done.
And I even agree that maybe starting in kindergarten
might be too early because when I did teach kindergarten
for one year, I referred all of them to speech therapy
and the speech therapist had to come and tell me
they're supposed to sound like that.
So I understand that there are issues
with doing universal screening.
And I think I agree with the idea of waiting
until the children are in first grade.
But I think that we're vesting too much
on what universal screening can do.
And that's the point our board president just made.
Assessment, particularly as it relates to literacy,
can have multiple purposes.
And with the system that this plan proposes to implement,
we're implementing a system of assessment and monitoring
that's identified and explained in the multiple resources
that have been identified,
including our guidance on language development.
Maybe a good way to make this plainer
would be to talk about the purposes of the reasons
why those references or resources were included.
So clearly we do need to explain and clarify
the state's intention and policy on universal screening.
I agree with the amendment that was made,
but I do think we should clarify
that universal screening is something separate
from the purpose of diagnosing a need
for placement in special ed.
But there are other types of assessments,
intervention planning,
to make database decisions for instruction.
We have guidance about that,
both in the framework
and in the language development guidance.
Progress monitoring.
That's the purposes of our formative assessment practices
and the other tools that we use,
particularly with English learners.
And diagnostic evaluation,
to identify a student's learning strengths and weaknesses.
These are the things for the people
who are truly urgently advocating
for this universal screening tool.
That's really more what they are urging the use of the tool
and that's actually not the appropriate use of a screener.
So maybe there just needs to be some time taken
to differentiate the types of assessment activities
that this literacy plan,
although I understand where each of these elements are,
that where this literacy plan
incorporates all of these elements,
so that we have a system of assessment
and not just a single tool
or a single type of assessment activity
that becomes the central focus of our concerns
about the work of this plan.
Thank you.
I'm looking to see if there are others
who would like to add on.
I'm not seeing any other hands raised yet,
but we will give you some wait time.
Thank you.
Member Petia Bronson and then member Rodriguez.
So I wanna lift up a couple of points,
some of which I think have been addressed
in public comment and the presentation
and then to name a couple that haven't really been so much
the topic of our conversation thus far.
I think the clarification that board president offered
around the purpose of the screeners,
what they are and what they are not
in terms of placement and special ed designations
I think could be helpful in a way
that might also allay some of the concerns
I think that have been raised
and also wanting to reflect that having this
at the beginning of kindergarten does have some challenges
and especially needs to address the fact
that kids are coming in with different levels
of literacy exposure to books,
to print generally and the potential
for both false positives,
but also just the potential to really,
to help think about what types of teacher training
and might be needed in different contexts
depending on what the demographics
of a particular district or school might be.
One of the questions that I have been thinking about
through the presentation and particularly,
I guess this goes more to Barbara.
This is a compendium of what exists already, right?
So I just wanna clarify that the existing literacy plan
does not require any usage of a screener.
It doesn't incentivize, it doesn't penalize
if a screener is not used.
This is actually bringing together what already exists
rather than prescribing what should be
in the future, is that correct?
That is absolutely correct.
I think the language that has caused
so much consternation today
is right out of California's Dyslexia Guidelines,
which is a guidance document that we have shared
with educators across California,
but certainly not a document that can't be updated.
Right, so we have been pretty consistent
in not creating any new guidance.
As I mentioned, we develop frameworks and policy,
you all do that over the course of many years
in a prescribed fashion.
So one of our kind of guiding principles is like,
we're not creating any new guidance.
We're gonna try and pull together the guidance that exists
and there is a lot of it in a way to make it coherent
and useful for folks.
So that's where the language came from,
but again, we can update that moving forward.
We're excited to have so many different dyslexia
focused efforts happening in the state right now,
the California Dyslexia Initiative getting up and going,
lots of good work happening.
It might be worth just bringing the Dyslexia Guidelines
to some of our experts in this area right now to review
and really have a robust conversation around screening
because the guidelines are now a few years old.
Yeah, I think that's a really,
I'm sorry, go ahead, Member Patu.
I just wanted to confirm,
so nothing in the adoption of the state plan
will preclude us from having that conversation
under different auspices?
No, absolutely not.
And no one is required to implement any of the guidance
in this state plan.
This is just our best thinking based on what the state
has developed over the years to support literacy instruction.
Great, thank you.
Sorry, Linda, did you wanna comment?
Yeah, I was just going to respond
and then I, Member Rodriguez,
I'll come straight to you in a moment.
So, I'm thinking about the fact that I've heard a number
of experts in the field say that our Dyslexia Guidelines
also could use updating.
So I think that the point that Barbara is making
on that score is potentially something
that needs to be thought about.
I'm not sure that for the purpose that we do need
to approve a literacy plan today to stay current
with the federal process that we are engaged in
and allocation of funds to the field.
I don't think that this question about screening needs
to be in the literacy plan for us to be able to move ahead
with the literacy plan.
And I do think a lot of the points have been made.
I mean, the point about who will be the screeners,
what's the expertise that's needed,
which screeners are we talking about?
Because there are a variety of potential screeners out there,
some of which may be multilingual, some may not,
some of which may be really focused more
on both literacy skills.
Most screeners, by the way, are not trying
to measure your literacy skills.
They're trying to measure sort of pre-literacy
and also other ways of processing sound
and text-based information.
But I think we really need to get clarity on that
and we need to understand what we're recommending
when we do recommend something
and maybe the best course of action
for us on the literacy plan today
is to eliminate those paragraphs that have caused confusion.
Even if they do derive from our literacy,
from our dyslexia guidelines
and revisit that whole question,
which deserves our attention,
deserves the attention of the field,
can supplement the guidance
that comes from the literacy plan
to allow people to move forward in a much more coherent way
with a common and shared understanding
of what we might be recommending when, how,
why, and toward what end.
So that would be, I think, my recommendation
on that piece of it.
Member Rodriguez.
Thank you.
Actually, Linda, can I?
Oh, I'm sorry.
There was just one more point I just wanted to-
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I thought you were done.
I apologize.
As I was reading the literacy plan,
I also was just really struck
by the degree to which we have really good disaggregated data
at this point to say in pinpoint
where some of our racial gaps are.
And what was also equally striking was to realize
that although the diagnostic work is quite strong,
the set of solutions that should accompany good diagnostics
were a little bit light as we were, I think,
and this is not at all a critique of the plan itself,
but it is drawing on what exists in the way of solution sets
to address racial disparities,
particularly for African-American children,
for Latino children.
And I think even though it doesn't,
it's not required for us to actually put this
in the state plan, but it does shine a light
on some gaps that we have of work ahead
that needs to, I think, be further fleshed out.
And so I really appreciated Board Member Rucker's comments
around how do we actually use the RFA
as a opportunity to build some of that in,
to actually structurally incentivize districts
or county offices of ed that receive these funds
to actually take this focus on
and create some of the innovation
that we're wanting to see that doesn't exist
because it's not in the state plan currently,
but could if we lift up local innovation.
That's a great point.
Thank you.
And the last thing I just want to say
is I love the early literacy, the inclusion of zero to five.
It is a step in the right direction
that it's both values talk as well as a 15% set aside
on the funding, so that's it, thanks.
Terrific, thank you.
And Member Rodriguez.
Yes, thank you.
So I'd like to really acknowledge all of Barbara's work
and the committee that put all of this together.
And I want to echo Member Rucker's
and then Member Patio's comments.
And thank you so much, President Darlene Hammond
for that clarification on the dyslexia
because that really helped a lot.
And I also want to say that the portal
for California educators together
is an incredible resource for teachers, for professionals.
And there's, excuse me, there's a lot in here,
but I did notice something missing
and that's national board professional standards
for reading literacy, language arts,
which I think would be a great resource to include in here
because it's very rich and it kind of follows
what we're doing.
And teachers can use this to improve
our own literacy and classes, so thank you.
I want to just before, I don't see any other hands raised,
but before we get to developing a motion,
I want to see if Barbara wants to kind of respond
to any of the commentary or questions that have come up.
I think I mostly just want to thank all of you.
And in particular, Member Patio Bronson,
just you're noticing like what we notice is not in the plan
or might not be quite right in the plan,
points us in the direction of additional work
that's ahead for us as we move down
with implementing this grant.
To be completely frank, I'm pretty thrilled
that our concerns narrowed down to universal screening.
There is a lot in this plan.
So I'm happy that the universal screening piece,
the how are we supporting specific groups of students
to be more successful, those are things that are reflected
in the statewide literacy priorities
that we want to sub-grant people to work on.
So I just want to thank you all
for all of the great input and discussion
that you've given both today and in January.
And I'm excited to get on with getting some of these funds
out and improving some literacy outcomes.
Sounds good.
Are there any other, I think I see Member Rucker
and Members Patio Bronson and Rodriguez,
your hands are still up in the,
if you want to speak again, leave them up.
If not, you can take them down.
Member Rucker.
Okay, so I just want to clarify what just happened.
I thought I understood the conversation
until we got more into the detail.
So I want to make sure I understand what we're looking at.
So there's a great deal of concern about the universe,
the language in the plan concerning the universal screener.
Not only what it says about the intent or the purpose,
but also what the source of that information
was coming from our dyslexia guidance
about the use of the screener and when to use the screener.
So did I hear correctly that the idea right now
is to make an edit that would just simply remove
those paragraphs, is that correct?
That is what I am proposing if others agree
that that should be a addition amendment to the motion.
Okay, so then in removing those paragraphs,
we have not removed from the plan the expectation
that the seven county offices who are the subgrantees
will in some way be accountable
for creating an assessment plan to deal with this issue,
but it'll be based on the guidance that we currently have
and we're looking at this as a living document.
So it could be revised or improved over time,
but it doesn't remove the expectation about an assessment
and monitoring plan from the work
that the subgrantee should be doing, is that correct?
That would be my expectation, that's right.
All right.
We can always add, we don't have to,
we can supplement this plan with additional guidance
on screening when we've had an opportunity
to really evaluate that and make clearer
what the intentions are.
Right, and so in making this revision,
it's not necessary for us to have that language
in this plan in order to go forward with approving the plan
so that we continue the work that we're required to do
under federal responsibility.
We have an obligation to approve the plan,
but our conversation about this work
and about the guidance the plan is intended to provide
doesn't end with this action today.
Exactly.
All right, I'm all caught up.
Thank you so much for letting me ask those questions.
Well, I'm sure everybody had that same question,
so thank you for asking it.
And I'm looking to see if anyone else wants to
weigh in on the discussion.
I'm not seeing any other hands.
Is there any other discussion?
I would like to invite a motion
that we approve the plan
with the elimination of those specific paragraphs.
And I see, oh, I see two hands are up,
Vice President Strauss and then Member Rucker.
So I'll move approval of the plan
with the elimination of the two paragraphs
identified by Board President Darling-Hammond.
And I will second that motion.
Excellent.
Is there any further discussion?
All right, I think that Brooks has had to step away,
so Judy Sias will call the roll.
Yes, Member Thun?
Aye, yes.
Vice President Strauss?
Yes.
Member Rucker?
Member Rodriguez?
Yes.
Member Patil-Bronson?
Member Nauvo?
Yes.
Member McQuillin?
Member Glover-Woods?
Yes.
Member Fatah?
President Darling-Hammond?
Yes.
And Member Burke?
Aye.
Great, the motion carries, thank you.
Terrific.
Thank you very much and thank you, Barbara,
for all of the hard work on this plan
and please convey our thanks
to all the members of the team that were involved
and we also appreciate the stakeholders
raising concerns that have raised for us
the opportunity to delve deeper
into this whole issue of screening,
which I hope will come back to us
so that we can get smarter and more focused
on how to proceed with that relatively soon.
And with that, we're doing well.
I'm going to call a lunch break.
It's 11.48.
We'll give you 32 minutes for lunch.
Let's come back at 20 minutes after 12.
Turn off your microphones and videos,
but do not leave the meeting.
Thank you.
All right, welcome back.
We are going to reestablish our quorum
and Judy Sias is going to help us take the role.
Member Sun?
Here.
Vice President Strauss?
Member Rucker?
Here.
Member Rodriguez?
Member Patil Bronson?
Here.
Member Navo?
Member McQuillan?
Here.
Member Glover Woods?
Member Fatah?
Here.
Member Darling Hammond?
Member Burr?
Okay, we have Quam.
Okay.
So we are going to take up regular consent items
five and six, and we'll open the phone line
for the queue for public comment.
We need the public comment slide to be put up.
Thank you very much.
So members of the public wishing to provide comment
on regular consent items five and six
may do so by calling the telephone number
and using the access code provided on the slide
that is shown now.
And there really is no board discussion before that.
So are there any public comments
on regular consent items five and six?
There does not appear to be any one for public comment
for items five and six.
All right.
Given that there's no public comment,
I'll ask a motion on consent for items five and six.
Do I have a motion?
I'll move.
Thank you.
A second?
I'll second that.
Thank you very much.
We'll now hold a roll call vote.
And Judy, will you please call the roll?
Yes.
Member Sun?
Aye.
Member Strauss?
Yes.
Vice President Strauss, I'm sorry.
No problem.
Member Rucker?
Yes.
Member Rodriguez?
Member Patil Bronson?
Yes.
Member Navo?
Member McQuillan?
Yes.
Member Glover Woods?
Member Fatah?
Yes.
President Darling-Hammond?
Member Burr?
Okay, Member Burr.
Okay, motion carries.
Okay.
So we are going to continue now
with our waiver consent calendar,
which includes waiver items W2 through 11.
And we will again open the phone line
for the public comment queue.
And I'll just note again that members of the public
wishing to provide comments on any of these items
may do so by calling in now
to the telephone number provided
and the access code on the slide.
Are there any public comments on waiver items
two through 11?
We might have one person for public comment.
I will open the phone lines now.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, caller.
Are you there?
Okay, I think this person is probably on the line
wanting to speak towards item number eight.
So this concludes public comment for this item
for waivers two through 11.
All right.
I just heard somebody say muted,
but I think I'm being too loud.
I'm gonna say muted, but I think I'm being heard.
Am I being heard?
Yes?
Okay.
Do I have a motion on waiver items two through 11?
Unmuted.
Do I have a motion?
I'll move approval.
Thank you.
Do I have a second?
I'll second.
Thank you very much.
We'll now hold a roll call vote.
Judy, will you call the roll?
Yes, Member Sun.
Sorry, a meeting.
Okay.
Yes.
Member Strauss?
Member Rucker?
Yes.
Member Rodriguez?
Member Patil Bronson?
Yes.
Member Navo?
Member McQuillin?
Yes.
Member Glover Woods?
Member Fatah?
Yes.
President Darling-Hammond?
And Member Burr?
Okay, motion carries.
Okay, so we'll now take a waiver item one,
which is a waiver request by the Whitmore Union
Elementary School District to waive portions
of the California Code of Regulations,
Title V, Section 11963.6,
which relate to the submission of an action
on a determination of funding request
regarding non-classroom-based instruction.
The CDE recommends approval,
and this item will be presented by Stephanie Farland.
From the CDE, this waiver is related to the next item,
item seven, the funding determination request
for the school.
So Stephanie, please begin.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond, Board.
So today we are looking at a waiver
for the New Day Academy that was
because they missed their funding determination deadline.
And so just a little background,
they did not submit a funding determination
by the February 1 regulatory deadline.
A little background on New Day Academy,
it's operated by New Day Academy, Inc.,
and they originally planned to close at the end
this particular school,
they planned to close at the end of fiscal year 2019-20
to come into compliance
with the geographic location requirements
outlined in AB 1507,
as it currently operates a site outside of its authorizing,
or did outside of its authorizing district boundaries.
Because it was planning to close,
it did not submit a funding determination
for renewal in February of 2020.
New Day Academy's closure plans included transferring
some of its students to Chassevue Academy,
another school operated by New Day Academy, Inc.,
which is authorized by and located
in the Columbia Elementary School District.
However, because of Senate Bills 98 and 820
introduced last year,
it introduced funding model changes
for the 2021 school year.
2019-20 average daily attendance is being used
to calculate funding for 2020-2021.
As such, Chassevue Academy would not be able
to claim revenues associated with any student transfers
from New Day Academy to the Chassevue Academy.
So it was then that they decided to reverse its closure.
Next slide.
Upon deciding to reverse its closure,
Whitmore Union Elementary submitted a waiver
to the State Board for New Day Academy
to submit a funding determination
after the regulatory deadline.
With their waiver,
Whitmore Union Elementary included information
regarding New Day Academy's compliance with AB 1507.
Both Whitmore Union Elementary and New Day Academy
confirm that the school is currently in compliance
with AB 1507.
The school previously operated a resource center
outside of the school's authorizing district boundaries.
However, that resource center was closed
on June 30th, 2020.
The school no longer operates a resource center
outside of its authorizing district's boundaries
and all program services are now delivered
via an independent study model.
The California Department of Education is recommending
that the State Board approve the request
by Whitmore Union Elementary
School District to waive portions
of California Code of Regulation, Section 11963.6C,
relating to the submission deadline
in order to allow New Day Academy
to submit a determination of funding request
after the regulatory deadline.
Approval of this waiver request will allow the State Board
to consider a retroactive determination
of funding requests from the school,
which is what you will hear next.
Without an approved waiver,
the State Board may not be able to approve the waiver
The State Board may not consider the retroactive request
and the charter school's non-classroom-based ADA
may not be funded for the affected fiscal years.
So that's the waiver portion
of this particular presentation.
Is there anything else you wanted to know
before we go to public comment?
No.
Okay, very good.
Before we go to public comment, as people are queuing up,
I want to ask Member Rucker as our waiver liaison
if she has any initial comments.
No, these types of waivers are usually something we've done
in due course, as Stephanie has noted,
this is not waiving the waiver request.
Stephanie has noted,
this is not waiving consideration of the request.
This is simply creating the flexibility
so that the application for the consideration
of the request can go forward.
And I know it's confusing to have both the waiver
as well as the action on the same agenda.
I have concerns about that as well
because of the concern about allowing time
for a public vetting,
but there are some timeline concerns
and that to support the request itself that were important
and that's why the staff had recommended putting
both this waiver and the action that's separate
on the same agenda.
And Judy can cover any of those concerns
if you all have questions about that
that you want to discuss after the public comment.
Great.
Are there any clarifying questions
before we go to public comment?
All right, let's see if there's any public comment.
Okay, I think we have one person signed up
for public comment.
I will open the phone line or actually two people.
I will open the phone line now.
Good afternoon, State Board of Education.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Michael Jubba
and I represent the California Teachers Association.
CTA is concerned with procedural steps
taken in regard to this waiver.
As highlighted on page one of the item, and I quote,
the CDE notes that typically
retroactive funding determination requests
are presented to the ACCS after an approved waiver
from the SBE has been received.
On page two of the attachment,
CDE clearly states that the New Day Academy
has submitted an SB 740 funding determination
for the 2021 school year concurrently with this waiver,
with the understanding that upon waiver approval,
the funding request will be reviewed by the ACCS
and required SBE approval.
Based on the procedural issues outlined above,
CTA questions why the CDE has allowed the process
of the funding determination to move forward
without the waiver being approved.
Thank you.
All right.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, it's Eric Premack
with the Charter Schools Development Center
speaking in favor of the staff recommendation on W01.
It's a longstanding reputable school.
The request here is in very much in alignment
with very similar waivers you've granted in the past,
and we support it and the related item seven.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Okay, it looks like that concludes public comment
for this item.
Okay, with that, are there any comments
from members of the board about this item?
Trying to get my participant list to show up here.
It's not responding.
So if you have a comment, please holler at me
because I'm not getting a response from my computer.
Okay, I don't see any.
Do we have a motion?
So I will move approval of what is recommended
in this waiver concerning this charter school.
And again, I wanna remind my colleagues on the board,
this motion is separate from what you will be asked
to consider on a separate action item on today's agenda.
All right, is there a second?
I'll second the motion.
Okay, any further discussion?
Can we have a roll call vote?
Yes, member Sun?
Aye.
Vice President Strauss?
Yes.
Member Rucker?
Member Rodriguez?
Yes.
Member Patil Bronson?
Member Navo?
Yes.
Member McQuillan?
Member Glover-Woods?
Yes.
Member Fatah?
President Darling-Hammond?
Yes.
Member Burr?
Aye.
Okay, the motion carries.
All right, thank you.
So item seven is the consideration
of a retroactive request for determination of funding
as required for non-classroom-based charter schools
pursuant to California Education Code,
sections 47612.5 and 47634.2,
and associated California Code of Regulations, Title V.
And so the CDE recommends that the SBE approve
the determination of funding request at the percentage
and for the time period as specified
for New Day Academy and Attachment One.
And CDE notes that it's funding determination recommendation
as well as the recommendation moved by ACCSR contingent
upon approving waiver number 5-9-2020 at this meeting,
which we just approved.
This item will be presented by Stephanie Farland of the CDE.
Stephanie, please begin.
Hi, I'm actually gonna let McKenna Huey,
who does all of our funding determinations,
present this particular item.
I will say before she starts
that the determination did go to these last months,
so we didn't skip any steps in terms of that.
They heard the funding determination and they approved it,
and they knew that was contingent
upon this waiver being approved.
So McKenna?
All right, good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond
and members of the State Board.
My name is McKenna Huey,
representing the Charter Schools Division,
and I'll be presenting item seven.
So item seven consists of a retroactive request
for determination of funding
for one renewing non-classroom-based charter school,
and that's New Day Academy.
So as has been previously mentioned,
typically retroactive funding determination requests
are presented to the State Board at a separate meeting
after the school's waiver has already been heard
and approved.
However, in an effort just to minimize
some of the negative fiscal impacts to the school
as this request was submitted so late in the year,
it was decided that both the waiver
and the funding determination item would be heard
by the State Board at one meeting.
And as Stephanie just mentioned,
this item was brought to the Advisory Commission
on Charter Schools at its February meeting,
and at that meeting, CDE staff did inform the ACCS
that its recommendation was contingent
upon the State Board approving the waiver for this school.
So as this waiver request has now been approved,
the State Board may act on the school's
funding determination request.
So the CDE staff reviewed the funding determination form
submitted by New Day Academy,
and upon its review, the CDE determined
that New Day Academy meets the requirements
for a recommendation of 100% funding.
New Day Academy spent over 40% of its public revenues
on salaries and benefits for all certificated employees.
They also spent over 80% of its total revenues
on instruction and related services.
And finally, they maintained a people to teacher ratio
less than 25 to one.
So detailed information regarding the school's revenues
and expenditures can be found
in its funding determination form,
which is provided on the ACCS meeting agenda,
as well as which is linked in the item.
So in conclusion, the CDE recommends that the State Board
approve the determination of funding requests
for New Day Academy Charter at 100%
for a period of three fiscal years.
And at its February ACCS meeting,
the ACCS moved to approve the CDE recommendation
that the State Board approve the determination
of funding request at the percentage
and for the time period specified,
and that motion passed by a vote of eight to one.
And that concludes this presentation.
I'm happy to answer any questions that the board may have.
Thank you.
President Hammond, I believe you're on mute.
I'm sorry.
We need to put the public comment slide up again,
because we're gonna queue up for public comment.
And while we're doing that,
and I will just point for those who are queuing up
that those who wanna comment can call the telephone number.
I've used the access code provided on the slide.
And while we're waiting for people to queue up,
I'm gonna ask Member Burr and Member Sun
as our charter liaisons if they have any framing comments.
Member Burr?
I do not.
Member Sun actually, I believe attended the ACCS.
I think this is self-explanatory
and McKenna did a great job.
Yes, I would agree.
CDE does a thorough job on these funding determinations
and it was approved by the ACCS.
Okay.
Is there any public comment?
I believe we have one person signed up for public comment.
I will open the phone line.
Good afternoon.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon, caller.
Are you there?
Okay.
It appears that they are probably on the line
for another item.
That concludes public comment for this item.
All right.
So I'll open this up for board discussion.
Is there any board discussion on this item?
I am seeing no hands.
Do I have a motion?
I will move approval.
Thank you.
Do I have a second?
Second.
Thank you very much.
We'll call the roll.
Judy, will you call the roll for the vote?
Yes.
Member Sun?
Aye.
Vice President Strauss?
Yes.
Member Rucker?
Not voting.
Member Rodriguez?
Yes.
Member Patio-Bronson?
I think you're on mute.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Okay, yes.
Yes, thank you.
Too many yeses there.
Member Navo?
Yes.
Member McQuillan?
Member Glover-Woods?
Yes.
Member Fatah?
President Darling-Hammond?
Yes.
Member Burr?
Aye.
Okay, motion carries.
Okay, thank you.
You will be surprised to learn
that you've earned another break,
but we have to set up for a public hearing,
and that public hearing may be a more extensive one.
So this is your chance to go get that cup of coffee
or matcha tea or whatever you're drinking this afternoon,
and we will see you back in 10 minutes.
Please don't turn off your, please don't leave,
just turn off your camera and your mic.
We are back from our break,
and so Brooks, will you call roll to establish a quorum?
Of course.
Member Sun?
Here.
Vice President Strauss?
Member Rucker?
Here.
Member Rodriguez?
Member Petillo-Brownson?
Here.
Member Navo?
Member McQuillan?
Here.
Member Glover-Woods?
Member Fatah?
Here.
President Darling-Hammond?
Member Burr?
Here.
We have a quorum.
Okay, so we are now going to take up agenda item eight,
which is a public hearing regarding a petition
for the renewal of a charter school
under the oversight of a local education agency
designated by the State Board of Education,
pursuant to California Ed Code Section 47605K2E.
This is the consideration of Ross Valley Charter,
which was denied by the Ross Valley
Elementary School District.
The CD recommends that the State Board
hold a public hearing to approve the request
to renew Ross Valley Charter,
a transitional kindergarten through grade five charter,
based on the CD findings pursuant
to California Ed Code Sections 47605
and California Code of Regulations Title V
Section 11967.5.
The CD finds that the petitioner is able
to successfully implement the attended program
and that the Ross Valley Charter petition
is consistent with sound educational practice
and meets the renewal criteria.
Although the CD finds that the Ross Valley Charter petition
contains overall reasonably comprehensive descriptions
of the required elements,
the CD has identified areas
where the petition could be strengthened.
The CD notes these areas in this item,
as well as in the analysis of the Ross Valley Petition
in attachment one.
ACCS recommendation,
the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools
considered this petition at the February 11th, 2021,
ACCS meeting.
The ACCS moved the CD staff recommendation
to approve the Ross Valley Charter petition
by a vote of eight to one.
This item will now be presented by Stephanie Farland
of the CDE.
So Stephanie, you may begin.
Unmute.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon again, Vice President Strauss,
President Darling-Hammond, Board, Chief Deputy Gregson.
Today we, as mentioned, we are presenting the item
for the appeal of the Ross Valley Charter School
renewal petition.
Let's go to the first slide.
So this is the first appeal
since Assembly Bill 18, or 18,
Assembly Bill 1505 has been implemented.
However, this is not an abusive discretion appeal.
So it is, while it is the first one post implementation
of 1505, it is not an abusive discretion appeal.
This appeal will look familiar to the State Board of Ed
because it is the first one
because the standard of review
for State Board of Ed authorized charter schools
requires a separate comprehensive review
of the school's academic programs and fiscal health
apart from the district's review and findings.
So it's very similar to what we have done in the past
in terms of the review that you're going to see today.
That doesn't mean that there aren't any pieces of 1505
that have gone into this review.
For example, the school was placed
in one of the performance categories
that is new under 1505.
They are a middle performing school.
And we did use verified data for this review.
So that's part of 1505 as well.
So there are pieces that will look new,
but for the most part, this is a comprehensive review
that we call de novo that we have been doing
for State Board authorized appeals for quite some time.
So before we start, I wanted to,
as I know there are a few new members of the board,
I want to give a quick review,
quick overview of the process and journey
each appeal takes once it comes into our office.
Once it is received, several members,
once the appeal is received to the department,
it is several members
of the charter schools division staff review the petition
and accompanying documents, including the fiscal documents
and analyze to see if the school has met renewal criteria.
The appeal then goes on to the CDE's legal division
for a legal review.
We also gather input from other divisions
in the CDE as applicable.
And then the final analysis of the recommendation
for the board is approved by the division director,
which is me, and also the branch deputy superintendent,
which is currently Lisa Constancio.
So it is a collaborative and group effort
and ultimately a department decision
when it comes to the recommendation for the State Board.
Next slide.
So as stated earlier, Ross Valley Charter School
is seeking authorization from the SBE
to renew their transitional kindergarten
through grade five charter school
within the boundaries of the Ross Valley
Elementary School District.
The petitioner saw authorization from the school district.
On November 10th, the district board denied
the petitioner request for renewal by a vote of five to zero.
The CDE received the appeal on November 30th
and the appeal went to the advisory commission
on charter schools on February 11th, 2021.
So the CDE recommendation is that the SBE
hold a public hearing and approve the request
to renew Ross Valley Charter School.
And as stated earlier, the ACCS recommendation
was also to recommend approval
to the State Board of Education
and that motion passed by a vote of eight to one.
ACCS educational program is a public school option
that provides a progressive education model,
emphasizing deep inquiry and exploration,
hands-on immersion-based experiences,
active learning by doing approaches.
Students collaborate effectively in teams,
they think critically, they seek information
to solve problems and be lifelong learners
and culturally competent members
of their diverse global community.
So the CDE's analysis and findings and concern.
We have, the Department of Ed has determined
that the Ross Valley Charter School
has met renewal criteria set out in Ed Code 47607C.
Due to the delay in opening of the school in 2016,
Ross Valley has CASP data for two years,
2017-18 and 2018-19, and as you know,
we don't have 19-20 data.
So we did analyze the 17-18 through 18-19 data
and it does show that the Ross Valley Charter School
does perform sufficiently by state metrics
in accordance with Ed Code 47607.2B3A.
We have a few charts here,
we have a few charts here
that will sort of highlight the CASP data
for the two years that I just mentioned,
17-18 and 18-19.
As you can see, they have made growth in ELA
amongst all students and amongst their subgroups.
Next slide.
Oh, it is the next slide, sorry.
And then this is also the CASP data for mathematics.
And again, have made growth for all students
and growth amongst all subgroups.
We added some of the dashboard data,
I do believe it was in the item as well,
but just so you can see it up here on the screen.
For 2018, they didn't have data yet.
And then 2019, they were in the blue
for both ELA and mathematics.
Here are the suspension rates
and chronic absenteeism for the school.
Both of those are in the yellow
and I believe in the school obviously
will be on the line shortly
and can answer any questions about this.
But from what I understand, the suspension rate
for a small school, it was one student
that was suspended twice.
And I'm sure they can talk to you about that
if you have questions about that.
Next slide.
So the Ross Valley Charter School
has been under SBE authorization for the last five years
and CDE oversight for almost five years.
In that time, they have always been
in positive physical health
and they do show a positive ending fund balance
moving forward and a strong reserve.
It should be noted that
because they are under CDE oversight,
we have been working with the school
as their oversight agency
and are fairly familiar with the last four years
of their fiscal livelihood.
They do have, as you can see here,
a very strong fundraising history.
So the projected donations that they have put
into their projected budgets
seemed in line with past efforts
and appeared reasonable to us.
Here is a slide that shows the existing debt
the school had as of March 10th, 2021.
Obviously this has changed over the course
of the last several months.
We tend to get updates on their budget history,
number one, because we're the authorizer.
And number two, most charters that come up
to the State Board on appeal,
it takes months for them to actually
get to the board hearing.
And so any updating of their budgets
is expected and allowable.
And so here we show that what their current debt is
as of March 10th.
Next slide.
Also, the school obtained a federal PPP loan,
which has been forgiven.
And we do have a bank letter that states
in clear language that it was first.
This is something, because the school's debt
has been the focus for so many,
the department wanted to do its due diligence
and took the step of requesting
an independent third party, FICMAT,
which is the Fiscal Crisis and Management Assistance Team,
to review the debt load of the school
and provide their analysis and some context around the debt.
FICMAT has provided the superintendent and the board
with a report, which I believe you all have in your files.
They found that there are no reasons connected
to the level or purpose of the debt to deny the charter.
Our analysis concludes that the projected financial plan
set forth by Ross Valley Charter School
is fiscally sustainable.
And I believe that FICMAT's Chief Executive Officer,
Mike Fine, will be available on this call
to answer any questions the board may have
about the report that they completed.
So the CPE finds that the petition does provide
a reasonably comprehensive description
of all the required elements
and provides a strong education program.
However, there are a couple of areas
we would like to see in the petition strengthened.
Those have to do with an area in element A,
which is the description of the educational program,
and an area in element J,
which are suspension and expulsion procedures.
So element A, we believe that
the English Language Development Program
should be amended to include more detail
regarding the following.
Next slide.
So to state that the home language survey is completed
when a student first enrolls in a California public school,
state that the requirement for proficiency
on the English Language Proficiency Assessment
for California is a score of four,
and include more detailed descriptions
of the integrated and designated ELD instruction,
as well as identify the integrated ELD
and people monitoring these to occur
across all subject matters.
And then for the next slide,
for the suspension and expulsion procedures,
we just need them to add the following to their,
add some clarification around Senate Bill 419.
Next slide.
And then also some clarification
around the placement of a pupil
when it comes to the manifestation determinations.
So they have the correct language in their petition,
but then they had another section
that seemed to contradict it,
so we just need to have them clarify that in their petition.
And I believe those are the only two areas
that we have found where we feel
they need a little more clarification.
Next slide.
So in summary, the CDE staff recommends approval
of the Ross Valley Charter School renewal petition
with those two clarification conditions
listed in prior slides.
Also, if you'll remember, under AB 1505,
when a state board approves a school on appeal,
it must assign that school to either the local district
or local county in which that school resides.
So in alignment with Ed code,
this Department of Ed staff consulted
with the charter school,
and they had requested that the school be assigned
to the Marin County Board of Education for oversight.
And then we will include as a condition of approval
that the Ross Valley Charter School negotiate an MOU
in good faith with the Marin County Office of Education.
So this is a new step for us,
and so we're working through this and working it out,
and that's it.
That's it for this item.
So thank you, Stephanie.
So now we're gonna go to a public hearing.
I'm gonna open the public hearing at 1.16 p.m.
First, we're gonna hear from the petitioners
representing the charter school,
and then we'll hear from the representatives
from the school district,
and each side will have 12 minutes.
So charter school representatives, you may begin now.
So let's see where you are,
and let's get your slides shared.
So we will hear from the Ross Valley Charter Petitioners.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Luke Duchesne.
I'm the school director for Ross Valley Charter
and have been so for the past four years.
I want to thank you and your staff
for taking the time to consider this renewal appeal.
I also want to thank the CBE staff
for their positive recommendation,
the ACCS for their positive recommendation,
and FICMAT for their extra analysis
of our financial standing prior to this meeting.
I'm gonna start by providing a brief background.
Five years ago, we came before the state board on appeal
and promoted our three main goals.
One, that we'd meet longstanding parent demand
for choice in the Ross Valley.
We'd be more diverse
than the Ross Valley Elementary District.
We deepen our culture of collaborative self-governance
that empowers teachers, parents, and students.
I'm proud to say that we've accomplished
all three of these goals.
We have expanded enrollment
and plan to be at capacity in the fall.
We have attracted a diverse student body
and have created an inclusive, collaborative,
and engaged community of staff, parents, and learners.
I'm now going to introduce one of our fabulous
multi-age teachers, Emily Bello,
who will discuss our educational program.
Thank you, Luke.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond
and the members of the state board.
My name is Emily Bello-Corell,
and I'd like to highlight some of the important features
of our educational program.
First being our student-centered,
curiosity-driven, inquiry-based curriculum
that actively engages all of our students,
grade K through five, in deep, symptomatic inquiry units
where their questions are encouraged and expected.
Teachers help to guide the students
in their research process to uncover answers
to their questions in an authentic way,
where student choice and collaboration is highly valued.
I'd also like to highlight our multi-age classrooms.
Students spend two years at a time with the teacher.
They cycle through being the younger student
and the older student in the classroom,
so mentee, mentor.
And this leads to a deep knowledge of student needs
on the part of the teacher.
It creates a rich, connected, joyful community
where students are known and families are known,
and it creates a very comfortable type community.
Next page, please.
We have a varied and experienced staff
to meet the needs of our students,
including an EL, an intervention teacher,
a family outreach coordinator.
We also have a community council of parents and teachers
who help make decisions on a day-to-day basis.
And we have nine classroom teachers
that are highly experienced,
and an additional number of teachers in our support staff.
Next page.
We're proud to be a more diverse school in Marin County,
and this chart demonstrates
that our school population aligns more closely
with Marin's population,
which has been an important goal for us.
I'd just like to point out
that our Hispanic or Latino population is 27.8%,
our white population, 53.6%,
and 20% of our students are English learners.
Next page.
All right.
We're also happy to be a continually growing school
as more families choose RVC each year.
Presently, we're close to our maximum capacity.
We have 90 new applicants for the 21, 22 school year.
Over 20% of our students are eligible
for free and reduced price lunch,
which is three times the district's percentage.
Our English learner percentage is 20%,
which is five times the district's percentage.
We have a high retention and satisfaction rate.
We've worked hard to cultivate a warm
and welcoming community for all families
that values and promotes diversity,
and we actively incorporate diverse perspectives
into our school culture.
Thank you.
Thank you, Emily.
And as she just described our program,
we have seen great results
as borne out by the state test scores.
With our English language arts scores,
having 82.98% of our students meeting
or exceeding standard.
For math, 73.4% of our students meet
or exceed standard.
For science, 78.05% meet or exceed standard.
And then really looking at the year over year growth
from our two years of test scores,
you can see that overall for school-wide growth,
we grew in both ELA and math.
And then our white students,
and then our other subgroups grew substantially
year over year in ELA and math.
It's our Hispanic and Latino student growth,
our economically just advanced student growth,
and our English learner student growth.
And digging in further on our English learner student growth,
just kind of seeing where the kids came
when we first had them our first year,
and then their progress on the LPAC the year after
as measured by the California dashboard,
you'll see that we attained a high progress level
as compared to the state
and the closest comparison school in the district.
And then in March 13th when we found out
that we had to pivot quickly
to address the needs of our kids
when schools closed down in Marin,
we worked with our county health office
to quickly reopen in distance learning.
And we did that the first day after.
And we've had a hybrid model this school year
moving to in-person instruction in November.
And we are moving to full-time in-person instruction
after spring break.
And we thought it was really important to focus
on the social emotional wellbeing
of our students during this time
and ensure that we're continuing to provide support
for English learners and our special education students
with services for the duration,
including during the summer,
incorporating all of our key elements of who we are.
I'm going to pass it over
to our board chair, Sharon Sagar.
Thank you.
So we're really pleased to have moved
to our own site two years ago
with a long-term lease,
which helped to remove much of the community conflict
over having our school housed on a shared campus.
We've made several upgrades to our new facility
this past fall that have enabled us
to better serve our students,
including upgrades to our path of travel,
accessibility and fire, life and safety systems.
We're grateful to our excellent charter oversight officers
that we've worked with during our first five years,
Chad Owes and Matt Huggleston,
and they've supported us in our efforts,
as well as helping us to continue
to improve our systems and practices.
We've also developed working relationships
with other school districts
and have developed a good working relationship
with the Marin County Office of Education.
Recently, we were invited to present a workshop
to other school districts about our diversity
and inclusion committee's interactive newsletters.
So our diversity inclusion committee
presented to other districts,
and those newsletters were shared
to many other districts in the county.
We've also shared with our parents
and helped to build a more inclusive community.
We're grateful for the positive recommendations
for our renewal, and we accept
all of the revision recommendations
that have been given.
We always continue to follow cycles
of continuous improvement,
and we're addressing any areas that kept us
from meeting the high achieving designation.
Our staff is always working to better meet the needs
of our students and families.
We look forward to answering any questions
you have and hearing any feedback,
and we thank you so much for your time today.
Does that conclude the Ross Valley presentation?
Yes, thank you, Member Strauss.
Yes, that concludes our presentation.
Okay, so now we're going to hear from the school district,
and the school district will now have 12 minutes.
I'll turn my screen sharing on just a minute here.
All right, can everybody see the presentation
up on the screen?
So it's in presenter view, so we can't...
Hold on a second.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let me see if I can...
I haven't started your 12 minutes yet, so.
Let me go ahead and see if I can get this up.
How's that?
Still presenter view?
We can't see it.
Okay, just a minute.
Share screen.
Let me see if this one works.
Just a minute.
And...
That's better.
There, how about that?
No, actually, you might go back to the other view
because we could see the screen a little better, yeah.
Can you see the screen now?
Yeah, so that's better.
Right now is good.
Okay, we'll start your 12 minutes now.
Can you hold on one second?
Are you seeing it in presenter mode,
or just in just the regular PowerPoint mode?
No, we can see this full slide now.
But it's just in regular PowerPoint mode,
not in presenter mode at the moment.
Okay, hold on a second.
Just let me get this.
How about that?
It didn't make a change.
Hold on.
Sorry about that.
Just a minute.
Okay.
The technical challenges of remote.
Actually, hold on a second.
Let me...
It was working earlier.
Let me get back to share screen here.
Hold on.
Let me know if you want me to try, Shelley.
Okay.
One more time here.
And you need to uncheck the presenter view.
Yeah, like, let me look and see here.
Okay, I'm taking it off that.
And how about that?
It's showing.
Is it showing your presenter view,
or just on the screen?
It looks like your screen.
Okay.
Hit from beginning now and see.
Resume slideshow.
Let's see what that looks like.
How about that?
Still?
Still...
We need to...
Okay.
All right, well...
I think you're okay.
We can see it.
Do you...
The question is moving to the next slides,
but we'll...
There we go.
Okay.
All right.
We may begin.
Okay.
Hello.
I'm Superintendent Marcie Trahan.
I'd like to thank you for considering
the comprehensive analysis we've provided
as you make this very important decision.
No, hold on a second.
Unlike charter schools,
our student demographics are limited
by our district boundaries.
Comparing RVC to the district creates a misperception
that certain students are leaving
a district to attend RVC.
This is not the case, as you can see from this slide.
Unfortunately, neither CDE nor RVC
have provided the detailed enrollment data we've requested.
We welcome all students from all over the region
and embrace all families who want to come to our schools.
Now I'd like to hand it over
to our board president, Shelly Hamilton.
Thank you.
Hi.
Recently, a few people have asked me
why I care about this particular issue,
and it's actually a pretty simple answer.
It's because of the kids.
At the end of the day, the reason for our denial
is about what's best for kids, all kids.
Now, more than ever, they need a future
that they can count on and equitable outcomes
that support all learners.
Students going on to middle school,
academically unprepared,
and thousands of families across the state
whose lives have been disrupted
when their schools ran out of money
and abruptly closed their doors,
and many more in districts
that have had to suddenly adjust their classrooms
and budgets to welcome those kids back.
It's just not good for the kids,
and we shouldn't be playing high stakes monopoly
with our children's future.
And that's exactly why this new AB 1505 review process exists,
to proactively do what's best
for both charter and district families,
rather than have to reactively pick up the pieces
after the fact or make up for educational gaps
down the line.
As stewards of a greater good,
you are publicly entrusted to make this decision
for the educational future of our children,
not just on behalf of the families that attend any one school
or in any one district like ours,
but on behalf of all 6.1 million students in our state.
Today, you will make a precedent setting decision
under AB 1505.
Today, you will consider how the legislative intent
of accountability is to be interpreted.
You will decide how high of a bar you are
and how high of a bar you want to set in overturning
or in honoring the decisions
of locally elected school boards, like the one I sit on.
And having been thrust into this precedent setting spotlight
here in Marin, we feel the responsibility to be allies
with our school board colleagues across the state,
from LA Unified up the Central Valley
and on over to the East Bay.
And instead of speaking for them,
we've dedicated some time for you to hear directly
from them, from Mike Hutchison,
a trustee at Oakland Unified School District.
Mike?
Mike, are you there?
Yes, thank you.
Sorry, it's a quick small technical difficulty there.
So, hi, my name is Mike Hutchison
and I'm a school board director here in Oakland, California.
And I'm very happy today to be here to support our neighbors
across the Bay and Ross Valley.
The intent of Assembly Bill 1505
was really to strengthen local control
over decisions of granting charters and charter renewals.
And your decision today is going to have implications
for a lot of us across the state.
In Oakland, we have the highest rate of charter schools
in the state of California.
Many of those came when we were taken over by the state
and they were imposed on us by a state administrator.
Since then, the number of charter schools in Oakland
has only grown.
Where today we have roughly one third of our schools
are charter schools.
And of those 43 charter schools,
seven were approved by the county
and one was approved by the state,
effectively disenfranchising our community
and taking away our ability to control
who we pay to educate our students.
I'm really encouraging you today
to stand up with our statewide network
that fought to get this bill passed
and to back local decision-makers in these decisions.
It's very important for all of us going forward
and I cannot stress enough
that I'll probably be in Sacramento soon myself
defending our school district against
the charter renewal or application
of this charter school.
Please defend our local democratically elected
decision-makers, thank you.
Thanks Mike, we really appreciate you being with us today.
Thank you so much, sorry for that technical difficulty.
So now you'll are gonna hear from a local community member
who also just happens to be a national expert
on public finance.
Patrick, are you there?
Yes, I'm here, thanks.
Good afternoon to the board and thank you.
As was mentioned, my name is Patrick Murphy
and I live in the Ross Valley community.
I also have about three decades of experience
on public finance issues.
And I guess in the current environment,
I feel the need to state that I don't consider myself
anti-charter and in fact, I think just about anyone
who would look at my resume would pretty much decide
almost the opposite.
Saying that though, I am here to say that my review
suggests that Ross Valley Charter
is not a fiscally sustainable entity.
I come to that conclusion after reviewing the materials
that were presented as part of this appeal
but actually went back to look at the documents
that were publicly made available
in conjunction with board meetings,
going back each month to the 2017, 2018 school year.
From that review, the thing that stuck out the most
was the fact that RBC has been relying very much
on either one time money or borrowing
to meet their regular expenses,
make ends meet if you will.
I liken this to the individual who essentially lives
from credit card to credit card paying for daily expenses
and that gets them to the end of the month.
At any one time, the picture might be okay
but overall, it usually ends badly.
And for a public school, this is not a great idea.
If we go to the next slide,
you've heard up to now that the financial picture
at least as determined by staff is okay for RBC.
I obviously disagree with that
and I think part of the disagreement comes from the fact
that the reviews have been done based on a curated set
of snapshots of the financial picture of RBC
and doesn't have the complete picture.
I don't think there's been the context or history
to make an evaluation of that experience
and perhaps more importantly,
there aren't regulations to accompany AB 1505 yet
in terms of what the standard is.
For example, we had in the FICMAT letter using
or at least referencing a private entity standard
to make a determination, which again,
doesn't strike me as a great way to make this assessment.
Perhaps my biggest concern, however,
comes from the documents themselves.
Those that were publicly available that I reviewed
have been at best problematic and opaque.
They were inconsistent in both their content, their timing.
There's no way to reconcile numbers
and in fact, at one point there was a very odd situation
where RBC had submitted to the CDE
for two different purposes, one for this appeal
and another to try to get deferrals,
be exempt from deferrals, which had cash flows,
which said different things
for obviously different purposes,
but again, quite troubling.
So from where I sit, I don't see RBC
as a sustainable entity.
I would respectfully suggest that you haven't been provided
with a complete assessment of its fiscal health.
I would note that the FICMAT letter itself
is simply a snapshot of one point in time.
And so absent those things and absent a standard
at which you can compare them,
I would respectfully suggest that you don't approve
this appeal, particularly for the precedent it'll set.
Thank you.
So similarly opaque is the academic performance analysis
that you were provided by RBC and CDE.
The numbers in the table that you see here on the left
were taken directly from the CDE report.
However, the CDE analysis does not represent
what was intended under section 47607.2B1.
This section in fact makes no mention of improvement
and instead it focuses on comparative annual performance.
All the green areas that you see on the tables
show that when you break down the data into the subgroups,
RBC underperforms the district at least 80% of the time
for both years.
And on the right side is an example
of the equity gap charts that we've provided to you.
Again, from a comparative analysis,
RBC's equity gaps are much larger than the districts,
100% of the time for both ELA and math and for both years.
And that's even with their second year improvement.
So about that improvement,
that actually is what's under section 47607.2B3.
And while RBC has been in operation for four years,
the only improvement data you have
is one single data point from one single source.
And you don't have any analysis to explain
why that data point is so inexplicably out of sync
with averages from other schools and districts
across the state.
One oddball data point from one source
is definitely not clear or compelling.
And since you can't get a full picture for all years
and all grades just from CASP scores,
section 47607.2B3 as envisioned under AB 1505
clearly requires other verified academic assessment data
in addition to state indicators or CASP
so that decisions can be made
on clear and convincing evidence.
Despite RBC's minimal CASP data,
RBC did not provide and CDE did not require
any additional academic assessment data
with which to substantiate your approval.
None, there's nothing.
So if you approve this appeal without this data,
you're setting a dangerous precedent
that doesn't follow the law.
And academic accountability seems to be one thing
that we can all agree on.
Without that and demonstrated financial sustainability,
you simply don't have what you need to justify
going against the legislative intent of AB 1505
in overturning our locally elected school board's decision
to deny this renewal.
And in closing, I wanna turn to Sue Ann Evans.
Thank you.
I'm not sure if it's switched on.
Yep, go ahead.
Thank you.
You've seen me here before.
I've been doing this for a long time
working in the charter world.
And I have actually been pretty struck
by how this process has unfolded.
You've certainly seen our materials.
There's been a lack of transparency.
There's been a lack of communication.
I've heard a lot today in the general agenda
about collaboration that has been entirely absent
from CDE and-
Excuse me, your time is now up.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
If you could look at the screen,
that's my timer, just that we're out of time.
But these are the options
that we're asking the board to consider.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So I appreciate both Ross Valley Charter
and the district for your presentation.
We're gonna open up the phone line
for public comment.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item may do so by calling the telephone number
and using the access code provided on the slide.
So let's see if we can get the slide up right now.
I need the previous presenter
to stop sharing their screen.
Thank you.
All right, so you're gonna call 712-770-5316.
Your access code is 433-7117.
So I just wanna remind you
to turn down the speaker volume of your computer
if you're following the live feed.
You will be limited to one minute.
And also I'm gonna remind all callers
that you need to be very respectful
when you make your public comments
to the board regarding this item.
So are there any public comments on this item eight?
Yes, we have 25 at the moment.
Please begin.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Is it me?
My name is Heather Bennett
and I'm a parent of two children
here in the Ross Valley School District.
I have been in front of this board several times now,
once bringing you a hard copy, I believe,
of what was over 2,000 signatures
of Ross Valley citizens and parents
asking you to please rescind this charter.
Please know that no matter how many people
may show up today to support our public school district,
know that it is not all of us.
We are the majority,
but this community is exhausted by this ongoing battle.
We need this to end.
Years ago, when I was president of the PTA
and as a parent at Manor School,
I saw with my own eyes how these very same teachers
of the charter turned away students with special needs
or who were brown or black or spoke a different language.
These same teachers are now exploiting these students
to try and boost their lagging enrollment.
And now, as so many of us fully expected,
when you disaggregate the-
Thank you, caller.
Your time is up.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
My name is Erin Heath.
I'm a resident of Ross Valley.
This is a precedent-setting decision.
The findings by the district's third-party financial expert
indicate this charter will be insolvent
before the end of the year.
More concerning, the analysis of their test scores
using disaggregated data shows a significant equity
gap between native English speakers
and English learners.
Their own director expressed concerns about his teachers'
ability to effectively serve their EL students.
This is a very real issue.
I urge you not to dismiss the district's thorough analysis,
which followed all AB 1505 guidelines.
The CDEs did not, and the individual who oversaw
the analysis for the CDE has been discredited.
The children of our state deserve better.
As AB 1505 intended, please rely on the exhaustive
analysis of the district and their third-party experts
and deny Ross Valley Charter's petition for renewal.
Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time begins now.
Caller, are you there?
Hello, my name is Paula Connolly and I am an RVSD parent
as well as president of our local high school's
parent club.
On November 10th, my community school board voted
unanimously to deny RVS RVC's renewal petition.
Prior to this meeting, you received close to 100
letters from members of our local community
who oppose this renewal, including one
from the California Teachers Association.
This is nearly double the numbers of letters you've
received in support of the renewal.
Please honor AB 1505 as you make this precedent
setting decision.
Please honor our local school board and our local
communities who are intimately familiar with the operations
of RVC and have the best interest of the students
at heart. Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond
and board members.
My name is Gina Plait from the California Charter
Schools Association speaking in strong support
of Ross Valley Charter School.
CCSA has worked with Ross Valley, the team for the last
five years, initially on their original submission.
We supported them through their approval.
We worked as thought partners throughout their term
and we're now advocating for their renewal.
Five years ago, Ross Valley made a commitment to this board,
their community, and most importantly,
their students to serve them with excellence.
And they've made good on that promise.
They meet all renewal criteria under the applicable renewal
standard and their data and outcomes demonstrate increases
in academic achievement for all students and all subgroups,
which clearly grants them renewal for a five-year
term under AB 1505.
We kindly request your approval for the renewal
of Ross Valley Charter. Thank you.
Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Good afternoon. This is Sarah Kaminsky on behalf
of the California County Superintendent's
Educational Services Association representing
the 58 county superintendents and schools.
This designation by the board, in this case,
to a county office, is the first of its kind under AB 1505.
There are two more renewal appeals coming to the board
in May and potentially more than 30 to follow.
We want these designations to be successful both
for the students and for the new authorizer.
This means being able to participate in the consultation
and lead up to the board's designation.
It means having time to operationalize
these new responsibilities and it means having process.
Not every designation will go to a county office
but we hope to be your partner in building out
this new process.
We look forward to working with the board to ensure
future authorizer transfers will be successful under AB 1505.
Thank you for your time.
Hello, caller. Please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Good afternoon, members of the board.
My name is Edward Yates.
I'm a government transparency attorney
in San Francisco, California.
I represent Robin Goldman in regard to RBC's petition.
I requested the board provide me an extra 30 seconds or so
given the time and trouble Ms. Goldman has taken in this case
and that she's retained me.
This board should deny RBC's petition
because of the disturbing pattern of incompetence
by CDE staff and oversight of RBC.
Not Mr. Thurman but the civil service staff in the CSD.
CD staff appear to deliberately violate the public record draft
several times in the last three years
by withholding records that were only released
when I had to make a demand
and your general counsel prudently released the records.
Other incompetence, CDE staff possibly violated FERPA
and civil rights of all RBC children
by sending my client.
No, you said to cut them off.
Do we have another caller?
The last caller, you were accidentally cut off by me.
My apologies. Please call back in.
Hello caller. Please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi. My name is Kim Lewis and I'm a parent
in the school district.
As a parent within the school district and an accountant
I'd like to point out that RBC's presentation
of their financial position is vastly different
than what's being presented here.
What was presented at school board meetings
was almost a million dollars in debt versus the 400,000
shown here in analysis of the in here of the analysis
of the independent accountant of their information
shows they are not economically viable.
Please listen to the consultant and our local board
as they have been monitoring you properly
as the CDE has not done so.
I encourage you to deny this charter.
Hello caller. Please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Good afternoon. Carlos Machado with the
California School Boards Association.
CSBA supports the Ross Valley School District's
denial of the renewal of the Ross Valley charter petition.
The legislature clearly intended to return charter
schools to local control through AB 1505.
This is because local school districts
and county offices of education are better suited
to understand the educational needs of students
in their area and the community impacts of charter schools.
By approving a renewal that the district board voted down
by a five to zero vote the state board will remove
the important local control built into current law.
The board of trustees vote was based on reasonable concerns
including the debt held by the charter school.
As a result the SBA urges the board to deny
the renewal petition of Ross Valley Charter. Thank you.
Hello caller. Please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Rob said excuse me Rob Sandusky a community member
and parent.
I ask the SBE to honor the decision of the Ross Valley
school district in the intent of AB 1505
and their denial of the Ross Valley Charter's
renewal petition.
To override the recommendation of local publicly elected
officials announced a taxation without representation.
The review of the Ross Valley charter schools program
by RBSD was extensive thorough and based on expert testimony
and years of experience with RBC and their leadership.
Many red flags were raised in the RBSD report.
Importantly the disaggregated information data showing
an achievement gap and underserving of heavily
recruited DLL students and across the program finance
and governance.
It should have triggered a complete and thorough
independent audit of RBC's entire program.
That this hasn't been done previously despite five
years of complaints by the district and the local
community to the CDE demonstrates insufficient
oversight by RBC's authorizing agency.
Again I ask the SBE honor AB 1505 and the findings
of the locally elected RBSD officials or at least
conduct a complete thorough and independent audit
of the data related to the Ross Valley.
Thank you caller, your time is up.
Hello caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute, your time begins now.
Good afternoon, my name is John Buettler
and I'm a Ross Valley community member
and I strongly support the Ross Valley Charter School
and the tremendous benefits it has brought to our community.
While our school district has engaged in incredibly
dishonest and aggressive assault on the charter
and singled out its most valuable and vulnerable families,
RBC has instead focused on serving its diverse students,
building community with their families while providing
them an exemplary meaningful education.
RBC has more than earned a five year renewal.
Thank you for your time.
Hello caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record.
You have one minute, your time begins now.
Hi, my name is Merrill Machino and I'm an RBC parent.
I also have another caller on this line,
so I'm asking for two minutes for two different,
you know one minute each for two different callers.
As an RBC parent it's really sad to hear the misinformation
that our local school district has been spreading
to its families about our school.
And that's a lot of the calls that you're hearing,
it's coming straight from the school district.
For our family moving to RBC from the Ross Valley
School District made a night and day difference
in the engagement and academic success of our kids.
Having classrooms where children are recognized,
understood and having their curiosity
channeled constructively makes kids feel valued.
It was not how they felt in the school district.
It's wonderful to see our kids actually engaged in school,
want to go to school and be able to shine academically
and have their test scores improve.
RBC is a safe and welcoming school
for all children and families.
Thank you caller, your time is up.
Hello caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record, your time begins now.
Are you there caller?
Hello caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record, your time begins now.
State board members, my name is Lorraine Richards
and I am representing the California Teacher's Association.
CTA is concerned with the CBE's approach
to Ross Valley charter appeal.
It undermines the intent of the legislature
regarding the renewal process
with state board authorized charters under 47605.9.
The district board voted unanimously
to deny the renewal petition
and issued notices of violation as outlined in 47607E.
RBC has challenged the district's authority
to issue notices of violation,
but not to other aspects of their authority
to consider its renewal petition.
This position is untenable
and it disregards the legislative intent of AB 1505
to return chartering authority from the state board
to local educational agencies.
CTA requests that CBE and state board address
these concerns so that the process moving forward
for state board authorized charters
respects the clear intent of the legislature.
Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi.
Hello, my name is Michael Miller
and I'm a parent of a RBC nine-year-old.
My daughter, she goes there in Fairfax
and she had previously been in a private school in Marin
and was having some difficulties with reading and math
and that was before the pandemic.
Her needs weren't being properly addressed
and in fact, her progress reports were very negative
and critical and not very empathetic with her situation.
When the pandemic hit her prior school was ill-equipped
to handle the online learning
and I was expected to print out most of the assignments
myself and it was very time consuming and difficult.
My wife and I felt so lost with nowhere to turn.
Then we were so fortunate to find RBC.
From the beginning, we were warmly welcomed
by the entire staff.
They generally care about our daughter
and put a solid plan together for her future development
and she has been blossoming since she's been at RBC
and I'm so happy.
I don't know where we would be without them.
We are so appreciative of their efforts.
They truly care about us.
Your time is up, caller.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi, my name is Victoria Kambi and my son goes to RBC.
He's a young third grade long haired American Indian boy
and he he loves his school.
A school creates a unique and inspiring academic place
for him socially emotionally supportive creative
and inspiring inclusive community.
And I want my that I wanted for my child.
I've worked at two different schools
at Ross Valley School District and although they have
a lot of strengths right now they were not a good
fit for my family.
If Ross Valley School District is concerned
about the best interests of the children
I would hope that they would be inclusive
and support the thriving community of RBC
which has been a gift for my family.
Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
My name is David Drury.
I live in the Ross Valley District
and I've been a parent and volunteer at RBC
for the last three years.
The one size fits all approach
that traditional public schools offer
does not work for all kids.
It's great to see charts and graphs and theories
and all that but as a volunteer I have seen firsthand
the transformation of kids who have come to RBC.
I'm talking about kids with severe learning disabilities
English language challenges or sensitivities
that don't find a place in traditional schools.
There was this one kid,
all the public school could do with him
was lock him in a padded isolation room all day.
When he came to RBC he was shown love and acceptance.
It took months but he came around,
learned to trust and found his place.
Today he is a model student.
That is just one extreme example
but the same model of love, acceptance
and individually paced learning
is happening for a couple of hundred kids every.
Your time is up caller.
Caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello, my name is David Talamo
and I'm a Ross Valley charter parent.
This is the fourth year my daughter has been in the school
and it's been a delight to see the diversity in the school,
the strength of the school community,
to have opportunities to participate
in what is a really strong school community,
to see the devotion of the teachers
and the broad array of needs that are being met
by students in the school.
As a result my daughter's a lifelong learner
and has a lot of enthusiasm for school.
As a marriage and family therapist
working in the community I see all the time
kids and teens who have struggled in school
and been turned off by it.
I'm delighted the school exists
and I hope they will be allowed to continue to do so.
Thank you.
Thank you caller.
Next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Are you there caller?
I just spoke.
Caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
My name is Zoe Soway and I'm a biracial
former Ross Valley Charter School student.
At RBC everything done in class
was made for students to grow their minds.
There were always ways to create challenges
or remove obstacles depending on each student's work stamina.
It wasn't names and dates.
It was stories and times of change.
When you walk onto the RBC campus
the walls are colored by the brilliance
of children's creations and all their stories to share.
You aren't just asked to put pen to paper.
You're invited to travel with the ink
to share and to think.
My best takeaway from the school was the connections I made.
Even as a seventh grader as I explore
and write about the suffragists in the early 1900s
and even as I run my business as an artist on the daily
I find myself turning to my teachers from RBC
to seek advice edits and different perspectives.
When you have a teacher at RBC you have a teacher for life
because at the Ross Valley Charter School
curiosity is empowered. Please keep this.
Thank you caller your time is up.
Caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Please begin now.
Hi.
Hi my name is Jennifer Frisch and I'm the parent
of a child who's at Ross Valley Charter School.
I wanted to express my support for the school.
My family has been welcome at RBC since we started
looking at it years ago.
The inquiry based educational model has really worked
for my child and allowed him to explore subjects
on a deeper level that he might not have gotten
in a different type of classroom.
My son is from a multi-ethnic background.
He's biracial and we have a very diverse family
and that diversity has been welcomed and embraced
at RBC in a way that they've never experienced
at any other school with our children
including with my older child who is now
a freshman in college.
The focus on social emotional skills has been key for my son.
This was never something that I'd seen in either
of my children's academic experience
and it is very very important for him.
Thank you caller. Your time is up.
Caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi my name is Natalie Long.
I'm a parent of two blossoming boys at RBC.
I wholeheartedly believe in public schools
and I believe that the traditional post-industrial
era system needs some serious disruption.
Kids are being forced to perform for the test.
They're stressed out anxious and depressed
and many neurodiverse students are shamed
for being different instead of celebrated
for their unique strengths.
I chose RBC for its inquiry based approach
and for being the only public elementary school
that had this child led approach inclusive
special ed and diverse lived lived experiences.
When I met with my local elementary school
principal she said I wish we could do that.
My hands are so tied.
I believe to create lifelong learners in a world
where we have no idea what the future holds
we need to move the public system to more
of an inquiry based approach.
I wish the Ross Valley School District would take more
of a partnership approach with us and use us
as an experiment to bring more child led
and curiosity fueled.
Thank you caller. Your time is up.
Caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute.
Your time begins now. My name is Julie Quater.
I'm a Ross Valley area resident
who strongly supports the charter.
RBC is a school that provides effective
and innovative education to a wide diversity
of students that your own state expert
confirmed is operating with fiscal health and stability.
I hope you will allow them to continue their important work
in educating those wide range of students
as they also serve their families. Thank you so much.
Caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
My name is Justin Taplin.
I'm a local community resident.
I'm phoning to ask that the SBE uphold the decision
by the Ross Valley School District
and the intent of AB 1505 and deny the renewal
of this charter.
I'd ask you to base that decision
on the overwhelming evidence and data
that's been presented by the district
as well as other outside experts
and not on emotional appeals and anecdotes
that you're hearing.
This is an important decision
and it has to be based on evidence
especially evidence showing that when you disaggregate
the data for academic performance RBC
is not meeting the needs of its most at risk students.
The district has spent years trying to work
with RBC leadership who have proven that they're
that they have severe financial and government issues.
Many of which have been outlined in detail
with supporting evidence here today.
Please uphold the intent of AB.
Thank you caller. Your time is up.
Caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Oh, hello. I'm sorry.
My name is Kimberly Hicks.
I'm a parent at RBC.
We chose RBC because of its emphasis
on inclusion in schools.
Specifically RBC passed a policy two years ago
to better support transgender
and gender nonconforming students.
The policy allows for students and their families
to develop a personalized support plan
rather than relying on generalized protection.
I can say that this policy has made a world of difference
for our child who feels supported and protected
by staff and the community
to express herself authentically.
We have been able to advocate for her further
through Ross Valley Charter's Diversity
and Inclusion Committee,
which is an active school community
of caregivers and educators.
And we're dedicated to amplifying the voices
of those who are traditionally underserved.
I strongly support this school.
Thank you.
Caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one moment.
Your time begins now.
Hi there.
My name is Steven Ledine.
I strongly support the state approving
the renewal of Ross Valley Charter.
I had two children attend
and they really benefited from the program.
My oldest joined with significant reading challenges.
And when she graduated, she excelled
in this unique learning environment
and the multi-age approach.
I found the teachers and staff to be excellent
and well organized.
I'm a bit stumped by the small
and well-funded opposition.
It seems like an emotional struggle for control
rather than a sincere concern for students
and improvement in learning as they state.
RBC is under great scrutiny
and I've always seen they've kept excellent records
and reports as a result.
The CDE's website encourages charters
to provide vigorous competition
and develop better learning.
And I think RBC achieves this very well.
I hope you'll make your determination based on facts.
Thank you so much.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello, I am Cheryl Flick,
parent of two at Ross Valley Charter School
and I wholeheartedly support the renewal.
I happen to be an accountant
and I can attest to there being a conservative approach
to budgeting and decision-making.
From startup mode four years ago
through and including this pandemic,
the district allegations to the contrary are simply false.
As a parent, I most love the integration
of social emotional learning,
benefiting all kids' engagement with school, including mine.
And I celebrate the school's radically inclusive focus
on serving students facing socioeconomic disadvantages,
students with learning differences,
and all the various differences of the rainbow.
Please renew our charter.
Thank you for your time.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello, this is Eric Premack
with the Charter Schools Development Center.
We've worked with the Ross Valley folks
since the school's inception
and always found them to be very resourceful,
competent, and focused on sound financial management.
We regret the very emotional opposition
by some at the local level
and believe it demonstrates the importance
of having the county and state appeal processes.
Based on my 30 plus years of in-depth experience
on school finance at the school district
and charter school level,
it's very clear that they're financially well-managed
and sustainable.
The debt ratios are normal for schools of this sort
and we support the CDE staff and its hard work
and the ACCS recommendation to grant the appeal
and hope that the board will vote to do so.
Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello, my name is Lisa Cana
and I'm an active public education volunteer
across multiple school districts
and I'm a resident in the Ross Valley School District
with no personal connection to RBC.
Marin County with fewer students
than neighboring counties consolidated districts
has 17 distinct school districts,
most of which have extremely regressive restrictions
on inter-district transfers.
We have segregation by zip code.
MCOE provides local control authority
with locally elected officials
and local government officials
to help with the process.
We have a special authority with locally elected officials
who can enable students to break through
these artificial obstacles.
RBC is one of the very few local public options.
Families with English language learners
and those lacking financial freedom
to defy geographic barriers and exert choice
to break down the artificial barriers to integration
presented by zip code.
Standardized assessments don't measure belonging
and inclusion, they should.
When families opt in, they vote with their feet
to demonstrate where they feel their children
are best served.
This program, having grown out of a district program
of diversity and hostility by its prior oversight body
and device of attacks,
hopefully once out from under these challenges
they can return to focusing on what they.
Thank you, caller.
Your time is over.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello, my name is Sam Lueck.
I am a father of two with RBC
and I appreciate the need for local control
as been discussed here,
but I think this is really important.
This process shows how important it is,
how vital it is to protect the interests of a local school
from a hostile school district and a vocal faction.
The facts and evidence in the CDE process
recommended approval,
yet the district and its supporters
are now attacking the process.
I think that's representative of their approach
for the last several years
and I'm really sorry it's gone this way.
Thank you for your time.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Are you there, caller?
I'm sorry.
This is Amy Flynn.
I'm a Raspberry Valley resident
who committed physical crime
in a attempt to rob the painting
at ER play center.
I have no hearing.
No, not at the theater arena.
At the library.
Are you there, caller?
Sorry.
This is Amy Flynn.
President, good afternoon board.
I'd like to urge you to deny the renewal of this charter,
which has never come close to meeting
their stated enrollment numbers,
which has had shady financial dealings
and has admired in debt since its inception,
which has had very questionable governance
since its inception, and which was denied not once,
but twice by our locally elected school board
and our locally elected county officials.
Please return the decision-making back to the local level.
Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi, my name is Zach Cortez and I'm a parent.
I'm an emerging learner here at RBC.
I spent the first half of my career
as an educator and advocate for children,
serving as a California credential teacher
and administrator with a master's in educational leadership.
Previously, I'd been skeptical of charter schools'
true impact, and then I had children.
Understanding the special needs of my child,
I knew the widely adopted approaches of public education
would not support my child's unique learning needs.
I was thrilled when we learned about the RBC community
and ecstatic when I actually learned,
was able to see the education in practice.
I am asking you to please renew the charter.
Thank you.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Vladimir Ivanovich,
and I'm a trustee of the Los Altos School District.
And I'm also pursuing a doctorate in education leadership
at San Jose State University.
My dissertation topic is equity and charter schools.
I urge you to, this board,
to deny Ross Valley Charter School's appeal of a decision
by the local LEA to deny their renewal petition.
I think there are procedural, financial,
and analysis issues should be taken into consideration.
But for me, there are sufficient and necessary grounds
for denial of RBC's appeal,
because of the abysmal performance of RBC
in closing educational gaps of our most vulnerable groups,
English language learners,
low SES, and Latino-Hispanic subgroups.
RBC does far worse than the district,
the county, and the state in closing equity gaps,
and arguably makes the problem worse.
I direct you to pages 43 to 50 of exhibit E of-
Thank you, caller.
Your time is up.
Hello, caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Maria Quintana Pilling,
and I am a resident of Ross Valley
and a parent at Ross Valley Charter.
I strongly support the renewal of RBC's charter.
Thank you for taking the time to listen to our community.
My son is currently in fifth grade
and has been at RBC since its start,
and I have watched him blossom into an independent learner.
One of the reasons I was so interested in the program
is because the kids remained with the teacher for two years.
This has been tremendously helpful
as my son is initially very introverted.
He is in fifth grade now,
and I would say that his first, third, and fifth year
have been his best
because he was comfortable with the teacher,
and the teacher understood his strengths and supported him.
He has embraced taking the leadership role
in his second year with each teacher,
and this has done so much to boost his confidence
and independent thinking.
Again, I strongly support the renewal of RBC's charter.
Thank you.
Thank you, Caller.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi, my name is Tanya.
I'm a parent of a child at Ross Valley Charter,
and I just want to point out the number of families
that are calling in and remind everyone
that while there's politics around all of this,
there's also a large number of families
who are very happy there and thriving,
and to not renew would displace so many children
and families in a time when the world is already upside down.
It's been the most diverse school
and social-emotional, and it's really a great place,
and I think you should renew.
Thank you.
Thank you, Caller.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello, my name is Emma Riggs, and I'm a parent to RBC,
and I strongly support the renewal
of this phenomenal school.
I have spent a lot of time in the classroom volunteering
since my daughter began three and a half years ago,
and I am continually amazed by the level of dedication,
passion, and positivity of all the teachers and staff.
My child is thriving here in academic
and social-emotional development
because of the level of care and excellence
that is given to every child.
Thank you.
Thank you, Caller.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi, my name is Hugh Roberts,
and I live within the Ross Valley School District boundaries.
I have two kids.
Both went to Ross Valley Charter
for at least part of their school,
and they benefited greatly from being there.
The teachers are excellent,
and the school is a real asset to our community.
The reasons that the district gave
for the denial of the charter are not fair,
do not represent an honest statement of the facts
as is required by their duty under the law.
But the district opposes the charter
not because it is concerned about the RBC students
or the RBC finances,
but because it doesn't want parents to have a choice
on where their kids go or what kind of school they attend.
Everyone in this district will be better off
if the district spent our shared resources
on supporting the students
instead of trying to shut down a school
or move a valuable choice to parents in our community.
These are for the renewal of the charter.
Thank you.
Thank you, Caller.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi, this is Edward Yates again.
I appreciate you allowing me to call back in.
I'll continue my presentation on behalf of Ms. Goldman.
Other problems that CDE staff has caused in this process
is that they have possibly violated FERPA
and civil rights of all the RBC children
by sending my client unredacted attendance records.
Those records later conflicted
with what your CDE, CSD staff relied on
to make this decision.
CDE staff has apparently allowed RBC
and at least one other facility
to operate in a non-ADA compliant facility
for at least a year.
And notably, nobody's brought up the elephant in the room.
CDE staff failed to do any due diligence
in the hiring process
by hiring a failed former charter school CEO
who is reported in newspapers
who allegedly have made white supremacist statements.
This is the expert that CDE, CSD staff relied upon.
Given this disturbing lack of due care
and competence by CDE staff.
Thank you, caller.
Your time is up.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hi, my name is Paige Hersey
and I'm a parent of a kindergartner
at Mass Valley Charter
and I've been an educator for over 20 years.
My comment is simple.
Not renewing the charter for Ross Valley Charter School
would have a significant negative impact
on children, families and our community.
Ross Valley Charter is a thriving,
progressive learning environment.
Even amidst the pandemic,
my child and our family have found a welcoming
and innovative school community at RBC.
The school successfully serves the children
in our community as evidenced by a number of measures.
Ross Valley Charter prioritizes equitably serving
a diverse student population.
I urge the commission to renew Ross Valley Charter
school charter to preserve a valuable option
that positively impacts children, families
and our community every day.
Thank you.
Thank you, caller.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello.
My name is Griff Roberts and I am an RBC graduate.
I would like to say that at RBC,
I feel like I learned more
in a more inclusive environment.
With the multi-age program,
I felt like I was more included with the higher age groups,
even though I only spent two years there.
During my year in the fourth grader,
I met many friends in many other grades.
And in my fifth year,
I could help fourth graders and I made friends in all grades.
I talked to people who I may have never talked to
and learned about one of my favorite hobbies there.
In those two years, I was mainly taught by one teacher,
Ms. Nina, who was understanding and knew how to help
the fourth graders feel at the same level as the fifth graders.
I still have most of the friends I met at RBC.
I feel like in RBC's inclusive environment,
people can help others and it helps stop age barriers.
I would like...
Thank you, caller.
Your time is up.
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Are you there, caller?
Hello, caller, are you there?
Caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Yes, hi, this is Peter Karnakin.
I'm a parent at RBC Charter
and I grew up going to progressive schools
and it was very important for me to send my son
to a place where he could really love learning.
I think that the attacks on RBC demonstrate
the amount of hatred and distortion,
the idea that there would be white supremacists at RBC
is a radical distortion.
It is, one could argue about the merits of charter schools
but to go to such a screen shows
that the opponents are not thinking clearly.
I hope you will approve the petition
and reinstate or keep RBC's charter intact.
Thank you.
Hello, caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello.
Hello, caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello. My name is Susan Lund a Ross Valley resident for over 25 years. RVSD's denial
is well within the parameters of denial based on AB 1505. After listening to the ACCS meeting
last month I find it very concerning that the CD CDE is completely ignoring AB 1505
by overriding the decision of our locally elected school board members to deny RVC's
renewal. AB 1505 was passed to expand local control by giving increased deference to school
districts our Ross Valley school district board to determine whether or not to approve
charter petitions and renewals. Please don't disregard our community or our board by overriding
our school district. Affirm local control as communities know best how to use their
public education funds. I urge you to deny RVC's petitions. Thank you for your time.
Thank you caller. This is a reminder to all callers that there is only one minute per
caller allowed for this item. Thank you. Caller please state your name and affiliation for
the record. You have one minute. Your time begins now. Are you there? Hi, good afternoon.
Hi, good afternoon. My name is Haddad. I'm a parent to a kindergartner. Being first time
parent it was not easy to find the right school but the multi-age inquiry based curriculum
of the RVC has made it easier for our family. Having a different background and me not having
attended school in the U.S. it can be a little confusing what to expect from a school but
the teacher is very knowledgeable. She is very understanding of different backgrounds
of the kids. RVC has given my kid different ways to express himself and bring his unique
creativity into the classroom. Our family has benefited not only from the school but
from the community of the parents. Not only the staff and teachers which is inclusive
but also the parent community has been able to, you know, add great value where we felt
supported and welcomed. I urge that the RVC continues and please approve the renewal.
Thank you so much. Thank you, caller. Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time begins now. Hi, this is Christy Kimball.
I am a former board member of RVC and a parent of two children who attended RVC. You can tell
I'm a little emotional about this but I wanted to strongly urge you to approve RVC's
charter petition. This school is an absolute lifesaver as a much needed free public option
that allows families whose children are not thriving in the local district schools to find a
better educational environment for their children. All families deserve choices for their
children's education, not just wealthy families who can afford private schools. I want to
emphasize that RVC has a strong track record in delivering strong learning outcomes for its
students. RVC students have consistently exceeded the performance of the local school district,
meaning they achieved a higher percentage of students who are proficient and or exceeding
standards than the district overall as measured by the annual state test in every tested grade
and subject since the school opened consistently. That's math, ELA, and science.
Thank you, caller. Your time is up. Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now. Are you there, caller? Yes. This is Christopher
Walgren, and I just want to say that Ross Valley Charter School has been a fantastic school,
strongly in favor of renewing the petition. Our daughter is thriving there. I'm somebody that
grew up in Marin and went to public school on a whole childhood in Marin, and I can say I did not
necessarily thrive in public school in Marin County, but at this Ross Valley Charter, I'm seeing
my daughter just blossom. Highly in favor of Ross Valley Charter School. Thank you. Thank you,
caller. Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your
time begins now. Hi, this is Sarah Tewksbury. I live in Ross Valley, and I want to say that I
watched the ACCS meeting on this topic on February 11th and was extremely disappointed. The behavior
of the commissioners and the staff was completely unprofessional, and ACCS did not do a thorough
review by any metric, and FIPMAT is not impartial, and to call it a third party is simply not
truthful. I urge your organization to not tolerate such blatant incompetence, and please don't
rubber stamp this. Do a real review on this and all future appeals. Thank you. Thank you, caller.
Thank you, caller. Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one
minute. Your time begins now. Are you there, caller? Caller, please state your name and
affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time begins now. Hello, caller. Please state
your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Hi, my name is Andrea Summits, and I'm a parent of former students who attended RVC. I really,
really urge and support the renewal of RVC. My children are now, I have three kids who went through
the multi-age program when it was at Manor School and then RVC, and now my high schooler and also my
two middle schoolers are, they reflect back on their time in this program, and they wish that something
was available like this for the middle schoolers in particular. They really felt like it was a nurturing
environment. It was a family and not just a school. And it really, I saw over and over again how many
children were, their needs were met in a way in this school because of the way this program is
designed and because of the multi-age classrooms and the intentional effort to focus on that
multi-age aspect of this program and the project base. Thank you, caller. Your time is up.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Are you there, caller?
All callers who have called in once appear to have been given the opportunity to speak.
Thank you. So since there is no other public comment, I'm here by closing the public hearing at
2.37 p.m. And now we will begin board discussion. First, we're going to ask our liaison,
Suber and Ting Sung if they would like to make some comments. And then when we move to board discussion,
just remember to use the raised hand in the participant panel. So I'll start with our liaisons.
Thank you, Vice President Stroud. So I really want to thank the members of the public who came and
provided their testimony and public comments today and taking the time to do that. I know that there's
strong feelings on both sides. But as we consider the appeal, there may be a number of issues that have been
raised that might have the potential of distracting us from the decision that we need to make regarding the
future of Ross Valley Charter School. It's extremely important that we focus on the merits of the
petition and whether the school has met the required renewal criteria. I also want to point out that
despite claims otherwise, Ross Valley Charter is an SBE authorized charter school and as such must be reviewed
under a de novo standard, not under an abuse of discretion standard.
So I just want to associate myself with Ting's remarks as well and just ask board members to focus on the merits
of the petition and particularly on the findings, I think, of our own staff, the Department of Education staff
on which we rely, as well as the thoughtful deliberations of our advisory committee on charter schools.
Because this is our first appeal that we've heard under AB 1505 and to Ting's point about the fact that this was a
charter authorized by the state board, not by the local board. I was going to ask Judy if she could just say a word
about the distinction between those two renewal standards and what's really before us. And also just to let people
know that with respect to the fiscal issues that have been raised, we did ask Mike Fine from the fiscal crisis
management assistance team on which we rely for all school districts and LEAs throughout the state to take a look at
some of the issues. And I just wanted to call your attention to the fact that we do have a thoughtful letter from Mike
about the issue of the debt. And Mike is available if we have any questions. So if I could, Vice President Strauss,
I see that President Darling-Hammond is back as well, asked Judy just to talk to us a little bit about the distinction
between the two kinds of reviews under AB 1505. Thank you.
Yes, Stephanie, this is Judy Sias. As Stephanie said in her presentation and members Sun and Burr have said,
this is an SB authorized charter school. Ross Valley has been a SB authorized charter school for the last four and a half years.
As such, the state board is the chartering authority and we have delegated oversight to the CDE as we do for all state board
authorized charter schools. AB 1505 did change the standard of review for new charter schools and also for renewal of charter
schools for most to an abusive discretion standard, as member Burr and member Sun said. That means there is a reliance on the
findings of the district and those findings can only be overturned if the board makes a finding that they had the lower board
had somehow abused their discretion. However, there is the carve out specifically for state board authorized charter schools
that before those charter schools that are coming on renewal, the law is the same as it was pre AB 1505.
And education code 47605.9 states that in those cases for SB authorized charter schools for their first renewal, like this one,
the board shall apply the law as it read prior to AB 1505 when making their findings. That means that today,
that means that's a de novo standard of review, as Stephanie and member Sun member Burr have said. Now, there were some elements of 1505
that were brought into CDE's review, the renewal criteria, for example, the look at verified data, the CAS data, which is on the verified data
list that the board adopted back in November. However, the standard of review is de novo. That means it's an independent judgment and
it's not going to be the same findings just like the renewals that you had seen in the past. This is not this is the first first one under AB 1505
but it is not going to be the views of discretion appeal. You likely won't have one of those until July. Thank you.
Thank you, Judy. I really appreciate the clarification. So we're going to go to board member discussion now and I'll ask you to raise your hand
and I see several. So I'm going to call on member Rucker, please. It's your turn and you can start the discussion.
Thank you very much, board member Strass. I have three questions, but I'll ask them one at a time so that I can leave room for others to ask their questions.
And you can come back to me for a second and then the third round. The three questions I have are about the finances because I am confused about the two different numbers.
The second question is about the enrollment and my final question is about the English learner and the English learner information and the condition that was added to the renewal.
So I will start with the English learner question. We are spending a lot of time not only talking about English learners and the performance gap, but also in a separate item.
We talked about the state literacy plan and the consideration about the development of supports and important support within the programs for English learners.
So I'm not really clear how the condition alone actually will correct or address what was identified as an actual weakness with the English learner program description that the CDE actually called out.
So Stephanie, my questions related to this are what exactly, I understand the county office is going to be responsible for doing the monitoring on this.
The only thing you have asked them for is to add some simple statements to the plan, but this does not actually clarify the protections that need to be addressed in their instructional program and how that will shore up the required supports for English learners.
Could you clarify that for me?
Yes, you are kind of cutting out a little bit, so I'm hoping that I got the gist of your question.
So we have had oversight of this school for five years. They are making tremendous progress with their English learners.
We feel that their program is a strong program, even during the distance learning that most schools have been going through.
They made extra efforts to meet one on one with their EL students, so they have a strong program.
I would say that the conditions that we've asked for in terms of strengthening the language in their petition really are, so it's clear that those three areas that we had listed, clarification around the home language survey,
the requirement for proficiency is a score of four, and the updated descriptions seem to be maybe just an oversight and not putting in what they probably should have in their petition, but doesn't really reflect the program they have.
Because we've seen the work, and our oversight consultants have worked with them over the last four and a half years, so we've seen the work they've put in with their ELs, which I think is reflected in those huge growth rates for EL both in English language arts and math.
And so we also, just so you know, and we do this for all of our appeals, we send the petition to our EL division and our special ed division within the department to look at their program and the language they have in the petition.
So, you know, we do turn to our experts to make sure that if there's some sort of lack of clarity in the petition, it's not actually a lack of clarity in their actual program and what they're doing with students in schools.
So I think, you know, we felt pretty comfortable having been the oversight agency and having worked with them, and our oversight consultants work with the schools pretty closely, that they do have a really strong program there.
And as I said, our EL division also looked at it and felt that they had a strong program as well.
Okay, and as I said, I have two more questions, but I will wait for a couple of other folks to ask questions and you can come back to me board members.
So, Member Rucker, stay with us. I just want to make one comment because we don't have any other hands. This is a time for board member discussion and deliberation, so board members can raise their hands and we'll call on you.
If we need clarification from district representatives or charter representatives, then we will call on you to clarify, but this is the time for board member discussion.
So, Member Rucker, go ahead and continue with your other two questions.
Okay, thank you. My second question is for the charter itself and it concerns the ethnic minority enrollment information.
I am always sensitive to the way information is presented about percentages and enrollment and actual numbers of students, particularly when it comes to students of color.
And when this charter was created, the promise was that it was being created to create choice and to create diversity in a very broadly diverse student population.
So, in seeing your numbers, you presented a lot of information about the percentages and you said that 1% of your students are African-American.
So, I'd like you to tell me what the actual numbers are. How many students are enrolled in your school? How many are Hispanic? How many are African-American and what the other ethnic demographics of your school site are?
Hi, this is Luke DeShane, Director of Ross Valley Charter. If you can give me a moment to get those exact numbers for you, I can come back with those. I just have the percentages in front of me right now.
That's fine. And when you do that, because this was something that was a part of the foundational goals, I'm sorry if you're hearing pounding in the background. I have repairmen at my house.
I've been trying to keep that quiet and ask my questions when they're not in the house. So, I apologize for that.
The second question I have related to that is what were your enrollment numbers in your first year and what is the difference between the enrollment numbers you have right now and the enrollment in your first year?
So, I can say just overall, our enrollment at the beginning of our first year was 122 kids total and we're at 204 kids total now.
And what was the ethnic distribution of that in your first year?
It was slightly less than it is now. It has improved over time. Again, I don't have those numbers exactly right in front of me, but I will work on pulling those up for you.
Okay, you can come back to me on that and I can go. I'll ask my third question. That's for our FICMAP person and I can come back to you if you don't mind that Board Member Strauss to give them enough time to get that data together.
That was in the, I believe that was in the slide, Member Rucker, as well.
Yeah, I'm having a hard time pulling it up, so that's why I decided to ask for that assist study information.
So, my third question was about the discrepancy or the difference between the numbers reported by the Board about what the obligations are of the charter and the numbers that were reported by the charter.
And so, Michael, I'd like to ask you to explain to me, are the reasons why they're reporting such a broad difference in what the obligations are is because they didn't look at the same things or the Board considered other things as obligations that the charter did not have to report as an obligation.
I'm not understanding million dollars in obligation versus a six-figure sum of obligations. I don't understand how that big difference could be.
Thank you for your question, Member Rucker, and good afternoon, President Linda Darling-Hammond and members of the Board. My pleasure to be with you today.
Most of you are familiar with FICMAT and our work, but let me provide some clarity first before I answer this specific question. First, we are an independent state agency. We aren't part of CDE, so some concern about our independence. We don't report to the CDE or the state superintendent.
That's not the structure of our organization. We were asked a specific question about the debt levels here, and that's the only piece of the finances that we looked at. And, Member Rucker, to your point, what we started with was their last published independent audit as our starting point because that audit was accepted by the controller's office and believed it had every reason to believe that it's accurate and complete.
And then we worked through the course of this current fiscal year. So that last audit was as of June 30th of 2020. We started with those numbers, what was identified both as current liabilities and long-term liabilities, and that's a distinction that's probably not important to you, but is a distinction that's important in the reporting.
And then we ascertained the status of each of those and asked the charter school to disclose to us any new debt or anticipated debt that may be incurred in the near term. And we have validated each of those pieces, including with the third-party creditors in most cases.
So I can't explain to you how somebody got to a million dollars. I could look at the data and disregard those portions that have been paid off or forgiven. And if I disregarded that, I could get you into the $800,000 range, but I can't get you to somebody what I think has happened to somebody rounding off to a million dollars, and that's not the case.
Their debt on July 1st, the beginning of the fiscal year, was $432,000. All of that debt that is represented in that $432,000 has either been forgiven, paid off, or will be paid off by June 30th of 2021.
They've incurred additional debt during the year, one for construction loan of $355,000, which has monthly payments. So while it may have started at one level, it has gone both up and down based on additional draws of the debt.
So as construction proceeded, they drew additional funding out against their total approved funding. And then there is anticipated debt in June that is directly related to the state-imposed apportionment deferrals on school districts and charters, of which they will be impacted.
That anticipated debt, we've picked a number and just stuck with it, although I think you all appreciate this is a year full of change and daily revision, not only in our operations, but in school districts' finances.
So what we would anticipate, they may draw down in June to deal with state apportionment deferrals today, will be altered based on ESSER II, the December federal pandemic relief aid, the ESSER III, the most recent Biden, President Biden initiative, stimulus and pandemic relief, and then AB 86, all of which have transpired.
In the period of time in which we've kind of looked at the district. And so those have an influence on what their cash position would be in June and therefore how much short-term cash they need to borrow to mitigate the deferrals.
All that said, what we're anticipating is they'll have debt at the end of the year of $613,000, all of which is new this year.
So certainly if you added those two numbers together and they're not additive, you could get to a million. It would make no sense to add those two numbers together, ones at the beginning of the year, ones at the end of the year.
So member Rucker, the chart that's in our letter, and I can review it verbally, is where we have assessed that they are on March 10th.
We were asked to look at this on March 2nd. And so we took a look at as current data as we could. That is updated from first interim and should be reflected in their second interim data, which were, of course, due earlier this week to CDE as their oversight into the county superintendent.
Thank you. Thank you very much for your explanation. I do appreciate that. And then I'll go back to RBC. Have you been able to give me, can you give me the answer to the ethnicity question that I asked you?
Yes, I can. So in 2017, we had 26 Hispanic or Latino, which is about 20%, 20.6%. Two African, two American Indian or Alaska Native, 10 Asian, zero Native Hawaiian or other Pacific Islander, three black or African American, 83 white, one who identified two or more races, and one unknown.
One unknown or declined to state. As far as where we are currently, we're at 56 Hispanic or Latino, which is over, which is a 27.5%.
Five American Indian or Alaska Native, five Asian, which is half of where we were four years ago, zero Native American or other Pacific Islander, six black or African American, which is double, and 18 two or more races, which is 19 more or 17 more students than before, and then six unknown or declined to state.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
You're welcome.
So, thank you, Member Rucker for those clarifying questions. I'm looking to see if there are any other board. I don't see any more hands raised. I'm just double. Oh, I see one. Member Navo.
I have a couple of questions. I'm really struggling with the perspective differences that CDE has with the district about how to look at the comparative data and fiscal implications. I think I'm starting to wrap my head around it a bit, so I appreciate the questions Board Member Rucker's asked, which gave me a belief that I do understand where these differences are coming from.
For Stephanie, CDE, the middle track for this school, the only reason, if I understand what I'm reading correctly, the only reason it's in the middle track is because of one metric. Is that correct?
It is.
Okay, it is the suspension or the absenteeism. I can't remember which one right now, but yes, it's one of those metrics. Otherwise, they would have been placed in the high track.
And it would have never been reviewed in the high track.
Yeah, we would still do a full review, but there are different review criteria under each performance criteria.
So the only thing that brings it really into the middle track is the one metric. Yes. And in the five years, have we done, has CDE done its due diligence and oversight visits, audits, feedback with the school around corrections?
Absolutely. We do site visits every year. Obviously, this year we couldn't because we're all remote. So we did a desk audit, which was pretty thorough and comprehensive.
And we meet with the school once a month through phone calls, and we have done our oversight. And every year, all the state board authorized schools, we put out a memo.
I believe it's, and Judy might correct me, but I think it's in October where we have academic and fiscal memos for all of the SBE authorized schools.
So every year the board has been able to see where the school is, along with all the other SBE authorized schools in terms of their academics and fiscal.
We've never had any corrective actions with the school.
Okay, thank you. I'll pause there, Board President Hammond.
Member Darling Hammond?
You're still muted.
Thanks. Well, I appreciate the questions about the finances because that was one of the questions, but I think the other part of the conversation has been about the quality of the education and indicators there are generally positive.
We heard a lot of parents and former parents and even students talk about the fact that it's an environment in which they feel there's a lot of inclusion, that diversity, racial, ethnic, gender orientation, learner diversity, and learning style diversity is supported.
And so I think that that means a lot. That's the purpose, the primary purpose of choice in our system.
I would note I was looking up the demographics for the district as we were looking at the demographics for the school.
The school appears to be about maybe just a little under 50% students of color.
The district is less than one fourth students of color.
So the school has attracted a greater range of diversity, but also diversity of all kinds, I think, to its program, which is one that is all TH grouping is unusual in many places, and it's what families that are in this school are looking for.
So on those grounds and on the grounds of the academic strengths that we've seen, I would be prepared to move acceptance of the CDE motion.
Do we have a second?
I will second.
Okay, so Executive Director Brooks, Alan, will you please call the roll?
Yes, Member Sun.
Aye.
Vice President Strauss.
Yes.
Member Rucker.
No.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Navo.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Fatah.
President Darling-Hammond.
Yes.
Member Burr.
Aye.
The motion carries.
So Stephanie, thank you very much.
Thank you for all the callers and the testimony and for all the people who participated in this item.
So I just want to announce that we are going to go into closed session this afternoon to hear the case of Kapin versus CDE versus State Board.
We are going to continue the meeting tomorrow morning at 830.
I want to thank the public and let the board know that you should disconnect and look for the link if you don't have it.
There's a separate link for the closed session.
We're going to take a 10 minute break and we'll come back at 315 in closed session.
Thank you.
Thank you and thanks for chairing.